this is jocko podcast number 310 with
carrie helton and me jocko willink good
evening kerry good evening
i went back to the living room and sat
down on the couch
newspaper clippings letters of
recognition
and photos with important individuals
were scattered across my coffee table
the 47 years of my life were summarized
in a pile of images and words
my life story stared me in the face
one photograph in particular caught my
attention
it was one in which i was holding a
single tomato in one hand
and a bucket full of tomatoes in the
other
i was wearing an old blue t-shirt
and a pair of shoes that were ripped
my abuelo jose and my siblings stood
beside me
my abuelo posed with his straw
hat we were all wearing old dirty
clothes
the agricultural field
seemed infinite in the background
the color of the shirt i was wearing in
the photo
was the exact color of the shirt i was
wearing as i gazed at the picture at
that moment
i had to smile
thinking about how things in life came
full circle
i was now wearing a blue nasa polo shirt
and not an old blue t-shirt
it dawned on me that there is no secret
formula or magic for making dreams come
true
the only way to make a dream come true
is to have the passion the work ethic
and the foundation of a good education
to help
go from one step to the next
while pushing aside the obstacles
in life
and that right there
is an excerpt from a book the book is
called reaching for the stars it was
written by a gentleman by the name of
jose hernandez
who has had an incredible voyage
that led him from
those fields
picking tomatoes as a child
out in central california
and doing that to help pay the bills for
his family
and that journey took him all the way to
man's final frontier
space
aboard the space shuttle as an astronaut
and it is an honor to have jose with us
here tonight
to share his story with us
and also share some of the lessons that
he learned along the way
it's a great honor jose
thank you for joining us thank you for
inviting me a pleasure to be here it's a
it's a wild story and i kind of jumped
to the end there
yes that the the voyage that you've been
on the whole way
and the perseverance that you've shown
um
just an incredible story
yes i think it just epitomizes the um
the
american story you know of what's
possible here in this great country of
ours of being able to uh
reach the american dream uh if you're
willing to work for it you know i always
tell folks when i give my talks
i say look i'm a religious man i'm a
catholic man
but i also know
nothing's going to fall from the sky for
me
anything i want in this world of ours
you gotta work for it and and and i my
father taught me that at a very young
age and you saw that fact that working
with my grandfather in the fields
picking tomatoes i mean they taught us
that work ethic and they said nothing's
going to come for free in this world and
i certainly believed it and i just
developed a great work ethic as a result
incredible
um
well you know if we're going to go
through the story we might as well go
through the story again the book is
called reaching for the stars
and
and as i read this story look folks
i can't read them i'm not gonna read the
whole book that's not what we're here
for but you gotta get the book to get
all the details the level of detail that
you give is incredible it's a it's a
there's funny parts of the book there's
sad parts in the book
there's triumphant parts in the book and
there's failure in the book so it covers
the full spectrum
of human emotions
and so if you if you want to hear the
full story you gotta get the book again
it's called reaching for the stars um
so i'm gonna jump ahead a little bit
here we go
i was born august 7th 1962 in french
camp california
at that time my family lived in stockton
california that is where the story of my
life begins i grew up surrounded by the
love
of my family and the many hardships that
come along with being part of a migrant
family my memory begins at the age of
five precisely as i s the time i started
school
i remember boarding this bus to school
when we were living out in the
countryside near the city of modesto the
school located in the small town of
salida am i saying that right salida
salida
seemed very large and was filled with
students who seemed a lot bigger and
older than me the classrooms were
decorated and filled with rows of shiny
new desks the desks had built-in
compartments that allowed us to store
pencils crayons and papers i could not
believe i was assigned my own beautiful
desk
phrases of gratitude were silently
running through my head
but all i could do was stare at the
blackboard because i did not speak the
language
i tried to figure out the meaning of
what was written down and drawn in
colored chalk i never dared to raise my
hand to ask a question let alone answer
one i also never fully participated in
any of the classroom kindergarten
activities like singing storytelling or
playing board games
it came as no surprise that my
kindergarten teacher whom i called la
mastra
spoke only english
she was not sure i understood everything
that was being taught much less being
said
i remained silent with the hope of being
invisible to everyone
so
that's what it kicks off
going into school no english zero
yes and and the teachers they're just
teaching in english and that's that
exactly deal with it in in in those days
there weren't any programs like english
as a second language where they put you
and they try to uh beef up your english
skills they just threw you in the
general population and uh you sank or
swam you know and then and that's the
way it was and you know if there's uh
proponents that say that's the way it
should be and there's others that say no
we need an english a second language a
as a program to help the weaker students
uh and so but in that particular case i
had no choice i was just thrown in there
what do you think what's the way to do
it just straight immersion what's your
opinion when i went to college i took
spanish
yeah i took three semesters of spanish
and i had a friend that's mexican that i
took spanish with and he grew up
speaking spanish i got better grades
than him in spanish class and i couldn't
i would i got done i could barely you
know i'd go to a mexican restaurant i
couldn't i was worthless i was worthless
at speaking but i learned like the rules
yes exactly yeah but i remember
sometimes the teachers they had the
thought the professors had the thought
that
you this is immersion
and so they would they wouldn't speak to
you in any in any english at all and i
thought to myself sometimes i thought to
myself i really wish i you would answer
this question for me because i don't
know i'm not figuring this out i don't
know what do you think i think it should
be a hybrid
because i think there's students that
will do well under an immersion program
and then there's other students that
really need that extra help
so that they can
get to that next level and i'll tell you
you know
my first experience in kindergarten was
um
uh
was
just as you described it there but it
actually occurred in three different
places because um
you know my story begins well before i
was even born my parents are from the
central state of mitrakhan in mexico
and my father at the young age of 15 out
of economic necessity was
comes from a family of 12 he's one of
the oldest boys
he had to come and work in california
as uh in in in in what he knew which was
agriculture
and he quickly set up a routine which
was common amongst those folks from
michoacan which was you would spend two
months in southern california ontario
chino area picking strawberries
then two and then you will move up to
salinas and you pick strawberries and
lettuce
and then you will go up to the stockton
modesto area for five months there you
start off with the cucumbers then the
cherries then uh then you got onions and
peaches and uh you and and tomatoes and
then you end the harvest with the grape
harvest and then he would go back home
for three months and cool his heels well
when he was 19 he met my mother from the
same hometown they got married and she
was the uh at the old ripe age of 14
you know which would have been a crime
these days now right but uh but but they
they got married and luckily my dad uh
incorporate my mom into this nomadic
lifestyle
and of course kids come along uh during
the
marriage right and there's four of us
i'm the youngest of four
and where you were born
dictated on what month you were born in
see i was born in august okay so you
were an american the last stop yes the
last stop i was uh and my brother was
born in september then i got a brother
and sister born in december and they
were born in mexico well getting back to
now imagine we were living this nomadic
lifestyle as a kid and spanish is the
only
uh language i knew how to speak right
now imagine the kindergarten my first
kindergarten is going to um in the
ontario chino area you know i
they they stick me in there just as i
learn where the bathroom's at they take
me to salinas and just learn where those
bathrooms are at i'm down to my third
kindergarten teacher in stockton and uh
and so you can imagine it wasn't a very
conducive environment to uh to learn
and that's that's eventually
why your dad decided to stay up in
america right yes yes as a matter of
fact um
in the second um and remind me to to say
some about my teacher at the end when we
blast off and all that because i always
forget to tell that part of the story
which is which is pretty cool but but
but uh it wasn't until i was in the
second grade in the second grade we were
in our last stop in stockton
and my dad gets up in the morning
about a week a week before um a week
before we go to mexico he makes the what
we call the
grana nunzio the big announcement
and the big announcement was he would
get up and say kids
we're going to mexico next week
talk to your teachers and get three
months worth of homework why three
months because that's what we stayed
over there and my father my parents
didn't put us in school over there
because
uh uh christmas vacation came along and
they said no no no no you guys are going
to self-study and so my mom would wake
us up every morning in my grandma's
house uh we would go to the kitchen they
would give us a cup of hot chocolate
piece of french bread
and from eight in the morning to 12 all
four of us
will be doing our homework you know the
homework was stained of chocolate but we
got it done
and uh and and so
in the second grade when he told us to
do that to get the homework i went to my
second grade teacher miss young
and uh man she was a
you know second grade who's your first
crush you know yeah
guilty as charge you know in my mind it
was me and miss young you know
and and and and i remember um she was
tall young uh asian and black long black
hair and tall relatively to a second
grader because now i see her the poor
thing is short but she was tall back
then and um
and i asked her for for for the uh for
my homework
and she looked at me with this
frustrated look and said you tell your
parents i'm going to come home
and talk to them
and that's when miss young came
and convinced my parents that we needed
to stay in one place and
and that's what sort of changed the
whole dynamics the whole direction of
our family and i love to tell the story
to educators
because uh you know i tell them hey i
know you feel like you're not making a
difference
but let me tell you one little thing my
teacher did that changed the trajectory
of a whole family and i tell them this
nice story about miss young and she
actually came to your house to meet your
parents
yes my mom uh when she when she told me
that she was gonna come and talk to him
that evening i went running home i
didn't even wait for my siblings because
they were in elementary school too
i went running home because i you know i
felt like paul revere right teachers
coming teachers coming you know with the
lamps you know and uh and and and i tell
my dad and my mom about and my mom of
course like any latina woman instead of
uh worrying about because my dad first
when i told him the teacher was coming
he started taking off his belt because
he said he must have did something bad
and i kind of backtracked and convinced
him it had to do with our trip to mexico
and my mom's different priority she
actually said we have to sweep and mop
and make
a nice dinner because the teacher's
coming and so yeah they pulled out all
the bells and whistles when the teacher
came i loved when visitors came to our
house because
you know we lived a very humble life i
never ever went to bed hungry thanks to
my parents hard work but i'll tell you
man we had our fair share of beans and
rice and tortillas and
salsa
but when visitors came
the protein magically appeared
in the form of a nice thin steak
you know chicken or a pork shop and i
remember i used to get so happy when my
dad would say hey your uncle's coming or
your grandpa's coming translation we're
going to have meat on the table
but but yeah see she actually came and
uh and she convinced and she told a
beautiful story to my dad to convince
him because my dad is a very um
what what well
how should i put a very uh proud man
and um
and i remember
after dinner they went to the small
living room
and and um
and my dad and ms young thanked my mom
for the dinner after she brought coffee
and
she basically said i didn't really come
here to uh
to to have dinner but thank you very
much i really came to talk
to you about the education process of
your four kids
and i remember this story because my dad
and mom did not speak english at the
time miss young didn't speak spanish so
i was the official translator since she
was my teacher
and and and when she said that that she
was here uh to talk about the education
process of the four kids
my dad immediately got uncomfortable
because i know what's going through my
dad's mind he was saying it's not a
complaint of one kid it's a complaint of
four kids you know and miss young saw
how how uncomfortable she he got and she
said no it doesn't it it's quite the
contrary senor it has to do
the fact that i've had the privilege of
having your four kids in my class and
let me tell you they all
love school they're good students i said
but this nomadic lifestyle that you're
living
uh is not
helping them
and my dad immediately stops miss young
says hey wait wait wait wait wait it
says
it's it's true that
that uh
my wife and i only have a third grade
elementary education
we're farm workers
and
and while my kids help me
in the weekends in the fields and seven
days a week during the summer whenever
there's school i said they're either in
school or they're doing their homework
they're self-studying i said we
take serious their education
and
miss young said yes but
you moved from
to three different towns three different
school districts
you know what my dad's response was
he said yes we but we move on a saturday
which was true we finished school on a
friday
monday we were in the new town new
school district and we were in school so
we didn't miss a day of school he was
right about that
and and then miss young would say yes
but then you go to mexico for three
months
and my dad says yes but they take your
homework
so in my dad's eyes he was meeting his
obligation
of giving us an education he didn't
realize that moving us around was
detrimental to the process the
educational process and miss young was
clearly frustrated
and then i watched her closely and then
she kind of smiles almost as she got an
idea
and
you know she must have studied
psychology because she she was brilliant
at it the first thing she does
is is is she caters to my dad's eagle
she looks at mr hernandez and says mr
hernandez
your kids tell me that you have
many years experience
in agriculture
said man
i think you can be considered an expert
on agriculture issues oh man you didn't
have to tell that to my dad my dad
starts pulling up his collar
so oh you know i'm not sure i could be
considered an expert but i do know a
thing or two about plants can i help you
and man miss young lets out a bigger
shop she took the he took the debate he
took the bait and uh and miss young said
well yes as a matter of fact you can she
said you know
i'm gonna give you a problem
and you can tell me what happens because
i think that's gonna help me
but i think it's also gonna help you
and my dad says sure what's the problem
she goes and she says imagine
i give you a
small tree
in a potted plant
i'm going to give it to you it's a fruit
tree and my dad says well thank you
so now i want you to find
the best ground fertile ground
dig a hole and you plant it
and you take good care of it like the
expert that you are
you're gonna fertilize it water it
everything you take good care of it my
dad says i can do that for you miss
young absolutely
then she looks at him says three months
later
i want you to find another piece of
ground equally as good
dig a hole
transplant that tree there
keep taking care of it
my dad puzzled look now says okay
and then miss young viral very quickly
says and in another three months what's
more every three months i want you to
transplant that tree mr hernandez but
you're gonna take good care of it
it's gonna get all the water all the
fertilizer all the nutrients it needs
because you're the expert you're gonna
take good care of it
then she looks straight in the eye to
him and says
now
you tell me
what happens in the long run to that
tree
oh my dad starts thinking starts combing
his mustache like he likes to when he's
very pensive and says well miss young
that's very easy
he says the tree's not gonna die
but you're gonna stunt its growth
because it's going to be weak and if
it's a fruit tree it probably won't even
bear fruit
why let me tell you why so a tree needs
to be in one place so the roots can grow
deep
and the branch even raises up his hands
the branches can grow
big and tall
and he's doing this and you can count to
two seconds
big and tall and then
you can see his facial express he got it
i mean he got it took him two seconds
but he got it because he sheepishly kind
of put his hand down
and i gotta get because my dad's very
proud but i gotta give him credit that
day
because he you know he could have uh got
mad or denial whatever
but he actually just looked at miss
young
and said
is that what you mean
and miss young said that's exactly what
i mean i think my job is done here and
she excused herself and she went off
and i'll tell you
that year we still went to mexico
but on the way back we used to go by car
and from stockton to mitrakhan it's
almost a three-day trip
on the way back that year
we didn't stop in ontario china we kept
driving north
we didn't stop in central california
salinas so we kept driving north and we
went straight to stockton
from then on that was our first and only
stop
and then our trips
back to mexico we still went every year
but our trips to mexico shrank from
three months to three weeks centered
around christmas vacation
and all of a sudden our education
started to get traction and why why did
it happen all because the visit of one
teacher and this is why i always loved
telling this story to educators i said
you just never know
what little c you're gonna plant that's
gonna give fruit and no pun intended in
terms of uh helping kids i said so
whenever you're down and out think of
this story because i'm sure there's
something you've done in your career
that's affected a kid you may not know
about it but i'm sure something that
you've done positive has helped a family
yeah no doubt about it that's uh awesome
story i know there's another thing you
mentioned in here that had an impact on
you
i'm going to the book it says star trek
was my favorite show growing up my
brother chava had a toy model of the uss
enterprise spaceship from the show which
was my favorite toy to borrow and play
with for hours and hours
in stockton we spent a majority of the
year
while in california we lived in a small
rented three-bedroom house located on
the east side of town it was an old
house made of wood with a tile roof it
had a small bathroom a round dining
table and a living room with old
furniture although the kitchen was small
it was always stocked with the
necessities for making a delicious
mexican meal tortillas tomatoes peppers
and onions the cuarto or bedroom i
shared with chava and gill had only two
beds a desk and a dresser our furniture
was rather austere and most of the
pieces were secondhand
the most luxurious item my family owned
was the black and white television set
and even that was
old by normal standards the street we
lived on reflected the humbleness of its
residents my family included with a few
exceptions my neighbors
made a living working either in the
fields or the canneries the canneries
processed vegetables and fruits brought
directly from the fields this is where
the tomatoes are packaged after being
turned into ketchup or paste and where
the fruits are canned to become fruit
cocktail
i came from a world bordered by
limitations primarily financial ones
fortunately as a child i occupied myself
with something that did not require any
de niro
because it was free no one knew about my
special hobby because i did not talk
about it fueled by the scenes
of star trek i spent my time looking up
at the sky especially at night at the
time i did not know exactly what it
meant mesmerized me
but there was something up in the sky
that fascinated me i spent hours in my
bedroom gazing through the window and
staring up at the stars
i stared at the stars thinking those
stars over there are twinkling and that
one over there is not
those over there look yellow while those
over there look blue
all of them appear to be the same but
they all are so different
so even from a young age
you were you were fascinated by what you
were seeing up in space yes and what
really helped was the fact that um aside
from
watching the first run star trek series
and william shatner who by the way
recently became a real astronaut right
he went up into space right that's right
he just did across the carmen line so he
uh he became an astronaut got his wings
but but um
what what really inspired me
was uh you know after watching things
like star trek uh lost in space and
those type of programs um when we used
to go out to the fields it used to be in
the early dawn it was still dark outside
and so we would go out to the fields
away from the
light pollution and so you're in pitch
dark still the sun
hasn't come up and still needs 20 30
minutes for it to come up i would go
outside
and you would go up and you let your
eyes adapt and you stargaze and you can
see the stars so clearly you know and
you know even clouds you know like the
milky way those type of things
you can make out that was so clear and
uh and those are the things that really
grabbed my imagination and i said you
know one day i'm gonna i'm gonna be up
there
uh you have a good section in here you
learned just an awesome lesson from your
dad
you say this as i grew older i would
this is that this is now you're working
you're working in the fields as i grew
older i would learn the magnus or bad
habits of the other workers this
included bending the bottom of their
metal buckets inward to create less
volume and thus appear to fill each
bucket even more quickly that's for the
cucumbers yes
i would also learn how to swiftly reseat
a bucket of papinos to make it look more
full when it was really not all tricks
of the trade i told myself this was how
we hernandez kids spent our weekends and
summers we knew that it was our
responsibility to do
and there was no way of getting around
that every morning spent in the fields
promised us the same routine of going to
and fro
picking fruits or vegetables from the
ground as the rays of the hot sun hit
our backs
during one saturday in particular i fell
over accidentally stepping on a yellow
overgrown pepino that was rotten
i remember its rotten stench as i threw
down my bucket standing there thinking
i'm all covered in mud i stink i'm tired
and i'm sunburned my siblings continue
working alongside my parents but i'm not
going to anymore i want to go home watch
tv and play
i decided to quit
i went to my father and pulled on his
pant leg to tell him dad i'm tired i
want to go home
when he heard when i told him he leaned
down
took hold of both of my shoulders and
with a surprised look on his face asked
what's wrong did something happen are
you okay
look at me i'm dirty i fell in the mud i
want to leave
plus i've already made 10 for the day i
cried to him the day's almost over he
said just keep on working i don't want
to
fine he said
take a good look at yourself
you don't want to see you don't like
what you see right now
you don't like working in the fields in
the hot sun or getting dirty am i right
well if you quit now you'll be creating
a pattern that is easy to conform to
if you don't work hard in school or in
life
this will be your future
is that what you want
no i answered him
well then don't settle for ten dollars
the day is almost over get back to work
he ordered with just the right balance
of authority and love and his version of
tough love
what my father told me that day in the
fields changed the trajectory of my life
it turned into the speech that
transcended the end of a long day of
working in the fields we would hear it
when all four of us sat in the back seat
of our ramshackle car father would turn
around to look at us before he would
turn on the engine and he would say so
how do you guys feel right now
we of course tired sweaty covered with
mud and we would answer accordingly
good he would say
because you kids have the privilege of
living your future right now
living our future right now we would ask
curiously
yes he would say i'm not going to force
you to go to school or get good grades
but if you don't this is the type of job
you'll have for the rest of your life
this is the future that awaits you so if
you want to quit school right now no
problem i invite you to start coming to
work with me every day as of tomorrow
my father's words made me realize that
if i continued going to school i could
do whatever it was i wanted to do in
life if i studied hard i might one day
make enough money so my parents would no
longer have to work in the fields to
this day i believe my father's words
changed the course of my destiny and i
am so grateful to him for that
i sometimes talk about the fact that
i think one of the hardest things for
kids to do is connect what they're doing
right now to their future they don't
understand that is that how hard they
work right now is gonna going to put
them wherever they end up in the future
and your dad made that connection loud
and clear for you all didn't it exactly
and he put it very well in saying you
have the privilege
because he said you know your neighbors
you know aren't working in the fields
during the summer they're off goofing
off and
having fun uh your friends they're in
the neighborhood they're not doing that
but you are so see they don't know what
their future is like
so they're happy go lucky carefree and
they don't care deadly squad about going
to school
but you know what your future is at here
it is you're living it
so you want to do this the rest of your
life
and i said man i don't want to do this
i think i'm gonna i'm gonna do well in
school because i want something better
than this and so so it was a hard lesson
i know my my kid one of my kids was
telling me the other day we were walking
through our town and there was you know
like a
some some homeless drug addicts clearly
on drugs clearly
just in a totally bad position in life
and they were telling me that when they
were little i walk by those people and
say that's what drugs do to you and they
remember that it's the same yeah the
same typical same type of approach your
dad took exactly exactly
left an impression on you
um
so now i'm gonna fast forward a little
bit again you got to get the book to get
the whole story i'm skipping giant
swaths of the book but
um
going fast forward a little bit here
things at school continue to get better
making friends became easier and
speaking english became less of a
challenge as time passed i did not
consider myself fluent in the language
until the age of 12 on the other hand
mathematics never gave me any problems i
had my routine down and i followed it
strictly as a soldier would every day
after school i would do my homework
watch tv and then play outside the only
things that differ from day to day were
the questions that invaded my mind i
made it my personal mission to track
down the answers to every single query
that popped into my thoughts constantly
pursuing knowledge while satisfying my
curiosity
you were into school huh
yeah you know what really helped was um
my father
you know in those days they um
they had the world book encyclopedia
and they used to have salesmen that
would come to your house and they sell
them to you
and i remember my dad they came one day
and it was expensive it wasn't this is
like 300 back then it was like 300 some
odd dollars or something you know my
parents didn't have that kind of money
but they bought the whole
a through z
selection glad they didn't just get like
a through e
exactly they bought the whole thing and
man whenever i needed to find something
out it's the good old world book
encyclopedia i would read it i would
even go to bathroom and take you know a
with me or b or whatever and you know
thumb through it as you do your business
but but that you know those little
things that my father did really uh
really helped out where do you think
your your father obviously he had this
incredible grasp on the fact of how
important education was where did he get
that from
i think um i think he got it from the
fact that he had been working in the
fields himself since since was 15.
he came even before then back at home he
used to work in the fields and
i think he realized he says hey i don't
want to put my kids through this
and when he saw when he came to
to um the states you know he saw
what people
uh would that had an education what kind
of jobs they have and that's what he
kind of
you know
wanted us my mother you know both my
father and my mother had they
have they if they had gotten an
education i think they would have been
well-renowned psychologists because uh
they were they were like expert
expert motivators uh my mother i
remember every friday we used to um
we used to
cash uh
the ch we used to get paid in the field
they still gave you checks paper checks
back then and um and so
on friday after work we would go
directly to a gas station chevron gas
station and had a little mini mart my
siblings would go inside while my dad
gassed up and uh they would buy you know
chips and soda
sodas and um and and i would say hey get
me one too because my mom would then
drag me like across the street to bank
of america
to to cashless checks
and um and i remember we were standing
there
inside the bank
it was about four in the afternoon hot
summer day about over 100 outside
and you know you're going to a bank nice
and cool right and that air conditioning
uh and so we're standing there in line
and i'm minding my own business enjoying
the cool the cool weather there
and uh
and then i i feel a tug on my shirt
and it's my mom
he said i said what's up mom
and she points to what obviously is the
bank manager and she says what do you
see there
it was this dude
you know a very nice tailored suit with
a nice tie and
dress very nice and obviously he was you
know one of the muckety mugs there in
the bank right
and i said well i see a man
and she says
no
i said i see you
i said look at yourself right now of
course i was sweaty
kind of dry cake mud on my levi's pants
and uh tired
it says look at your hands
and you know they're all dirty and
everything i said
this is why you have to point into my
head says this is why you have to work
with this if you work with this
that's how you're going to dress and
this is where you're going to work
in a place like this air conditioning
inside in the shade
but if you work with this
says your body is going to break down
you may be able to do it for a few years
but eventually your body's going to
break down
so she would always say oh ho i
you know
you better do well in school so they
both kind of like bombarded us from
different directions and uh subtle and
not too subtle ways of uh of making sure
and she was the one that was um
helped us develop the study habits
because as soon as we came home
you know my parents would always race
from the fields back home to make sure
they were home before we got home from
school so we wouldn't find an empty
house
and
my mom's routine was she would dart to
the kitchen
she would make her
fresh tortillas uh the beans rice and
salsa and that was the bait because we
would come home from school we'll come
home from school we were hungry
and she would sit us down and she would
feed us
but then we couldn't get up
he says crack open your books show me
that you finish your homework do your
homework and show me your finish and
only until then we would be allowed to
get up and go to uh play outside with
our friends but she was the one that
instilled those study habits that you
know came in handy once you started
college uh the fact that you had that
discipline of saying hey i gotta take
care of this before i can enjoy myself
here's another impactful moment fast
forward a little bit it was during that
particular summer of 1969 when a major
event occurred that would make a big
difference in my life
despite the war in vietnam the internal
conflicts in the u.s and the hippie
movement it was an important year for
humanity
it was a year that left a strong
impression on me at the tender age of
seven on the morning of july 20th 1969
the entire world was glued to the
television set waiting in awe for an
historic event to take place
mankind had managed to do the unthink
unthinkable a person was about to set
foot
on the moon
later that night the first images of
neil armstrong on the surface of the la
luna were transmitted into households
around the globe when he put his foot on
the moon and
he uttered the famous line
that transcended time
that's one small step for man
one giant leap for mankind
when i heard these words i felt
indescribably shocked i was captivated
by this man by this science which left
me in awe absorbed in the broadcast i
got up abruptly to get closer to the
television screen i had an epiphany
during that exact moment i discovered
what i wanted to be when i grew up an
astronaut
and from that moment on i was determined
that absolutely nothing would get in the
way of my dream
and thus the dream was born
there it is you remember watching that
huh yeah yeah it was such a big event
uh you know i think everybody
uh would uh
in in the united in the whole world
i was watching that because it was an
amazement because to think that
um
you know the apollo rocket and
the capsule
you know which has less computing power
than your average cell phone
was able to go and using vacuum tube
technology we were able to go to the
surface of the moon
send a couple humans down there and then
bring him back home safe and sound i
mean it was just amazing it was like uh
star trek going live you know for real
so i was just amazed and i was
you know i was saying you know this is
this is what i want to be
another
your parents are getting a lot of cred a
lot of credit today here's another
little point where they get a ton of
credit the only people i did share this
dream with were my parents and to my
pleasant surprise they offered me with
words of encouragement my father sat me
down at the same kitchen table where my
mother made us do our homework every day
and offered me a few words of advice he
said if i followed his recipe i could do
anything that i wanted to
when i grew up because we lived in the
united states he explained to me that my
siblings and i had the opportunity to
live the american dream
looking at me very seriously he said
first
identify what you want to be when you
grow up second know how far you are from
your goal
third
draw yourself a road map that gives you
all the steps it will take to get there
fourth get yourself a good education
fifth and finally apply the same work
ethic that you have in your work in the
fields
to your books
and subsequently to your job once you
graduate from college mix all this
together jose and you can be successful
at anything you want to do including
becoming an astronaut
yeah out of the gate and i took that
hook line and sinker because you know
when when you're seven and you're 10
years old and your father tells you
something you believe it
so if he told me follow this recipe and
you'll become an astronaut
and i took that hook line and sinker i
said
i'm going to be an astronaut i really
believed it at the time because i said
these are steps i can follow
and i believe my father and
this is why i love sharing that recipe
because it works
it works and this is why i uh i try to
tell people i said to reach your full
potential says follow these five
simple ingredients later i added a sixth
ingredient which is perseverance and
we'll talk about that a little later but
but i added that six ingredients and i
said you guys follow these six
ingredients i said you know sky is no
longer the limit spaces because i proved
that
you know what's amazing when you were
sitting there saying that when you're a
kid
and your parents tell you something you
listen to them i mean imagine if your
dad would have had a different attitude
imagine if your dad would have said oh
you'll never be an astronaut or you you
don't have the chance of doing it i
would have never been never would have
done it no
because i would have believed them i
said you know this is too monumental for
me and
where i'm at social economically you
know it's not for me and i would have
believed it my dad would have told me
that and but he didn't it sounded like
early on your dad especially was pretty
adamant about you understanding that
your future is your choice you know and
he he provided the alternative right up
front for you you experienced it you
know working in the fields um and then
so i've got to imagine
you coming to him with a choice you've
decided you know at this point as a
young kid that space is is it for you
you know being an astronaut so i've got
to imagine you know he was
really open to that and you know
yeah
and i'm certain
you know he didn't believe i could reach
it right you know obviously but but he
was uh so interested in us getting an
education
that it it's like you know
he said if that's what motivates him to
go to college finish high school and go
to college so be it right i mean this is
the same thing i tell my kid my oldest
kid he's a um
he's finishing up his phd in purdue in
aerospace engineering has two masters at
bachelor's
and um
and and
i told him you know when when i hooded
him for his first masters you were
standing there in line we had never
talked about his future in terms of
where he wanted to work and i thought he
was uh he was done with his first
masters but you know he said he was
going to graduate school and he won his
phd and i said oh cool great that's
great um
and and and and um
i remember i as a uh
we were standing there in line i told
him son why
why purdue
and he said that you know i took a page
off of your book he says i um
i made a list of all the astronauts that
got selected by nasa or they
graduated and guess which school has
graduated the most astronauts i said let
me guess purdue
they say yes including neil armstrong
and so so that's when i told him
you know that's when i told him i said
son
if wanting to be an astronaut motivates
you to get your phd i said you go on and
be an astronaut because you know what
once you get that phd there's going to
be a lot of opportunities opened up for
you you may not make it to be an
astronaut but i think you will i said i
think you can make it but you're going
to have so many other choices in life
with two masters and
a phd and bachelors and so uh so yeah
exactly powerful yeah
um your family eventually um
moves into a little place and eventually
buys a place yes eventually buys a place
you say here after a few more years of
renting my parents would buy this house
from the landlord the landlord
facilitated a rent to own finance plan
that i as a 12 year old kid helped
translate and explained to my father
finally the family had a place to call
home although our new barrio or
neighborhood was far from ideal it had a
slew of problems just as any other
barrio in south and east stockton did
since we were in the old in one of the
older more dispressed neighborhood we
witnessed far more crime than other
people who lived in the newer part of
town
i started to become more fast forward a
little bit i started to become more
social at school and in my barrio it was
at fremont middle school where i met
carlos and his older brother alberto
another person i hung around with in
school was my friend sergio he lived
across the street from me the four of us
were like brothers we stick together
through our adolescent years
we were there for each other in good
times and in bad times
do you guys know what a poacher is ask
carlos while we were sitting on the
stairs in front of my house no sergio
and i answered jointly apocho is a
mexican born here in the united states
who is neither a mexican nor an american
like us he explained
carlos and sergio wore those white
t-shirts without sleeves baggy gray
khaki pants and shiny black stacy adams
dress shoes that always look too big for
their feet
their accessories generally consisted of
a bandana either neatly folded in their
back pocket or worn around their head
covering most of their forehead and a
chain that hung from their belt loop is
it a bad thing to be a pocho i asked
no but in case you haven't noticed they
don't seem to like us here in the u.s or
in mexico they will pick on us here or
there that's why we have to stick
together if we don't we'll be easy
targets and they'll get us who will get
us
the gringos and the mexicans that have
come straight from mexico as i said they
don't like us when we go to mexico they
tell us that we're too americanized
meanwhile the gringos call us dirty
mexicans either way we can't win it's
like we have no roots and don't belong
and don't seem to belong in either place
i'm telling you that's why we have to
stick together
fast forward a little bit things around
my neighborhood were never easy gangs
were everywhere
they were they and they congregated on a
daily basis hoping to define their
territories drugs like marijuana were
commonly used and sold in arbario
drive-by shootings occurred to a lesser
extent but nonetheless kept the
neighborhood on edge families were
dysfunctional divided and grew apart due
to inattentive parents suffering from
alcoholism or other various addictions
the children from these broken homes
were quickly recruited to join gangs so
year after year the membership of these
groups multiplied
i admit that it was difficult to escape
that environment although i managed to
steer clear of such activities i had to
somewhat assimilate in order to survive
soon my appearance and attitude begin to
change
as i spent more time with carlos alberto
and sergio i became tougher and tougher
or so i thought i began wearing baggy
pants oversized flannel shirts and shoes
that were one size too big i walked down
the streets with an attitude while i was
emulating alberto's gestures
my objective was to conceal the true
jose while trying to look like the rest
of my peers
i did not want to be labeled a schoolboy
or bookworm so that i could avoid being
harassed
however when i was in class and with my
family i was my true self i was playful
studious and responsible but when i was
on the streets i was one of the homeboys
as we pochos would call ourselves
the price of assimilation was steep soon
i started to deny i knew how to speak
spanish and i began paying less
attention to my mexican
[Music]
roots so there's some alternative paths
besides the one that you were trying to
go down that's right that's right uh
you know these three friends of mine
that what age group what age are you at
this point this is a junior high this is
so we're talking like 12 13 12 13 14
yeah
yeah and and it's it's at that point
where
you kind of
you know there's there's some points in
your life that marks you that says hey
you know i've got to change the way
things are in in the direction i'm
heading because
i was doing that with my friends because
you had to do that in the neighborhood
but then you went back to school you
went back home and you try to clean
yourself up so that your parents don't
see like you're turning into a thug
right kind of thing and and and
and then you start thinking about okay
i'm doing this more and more and more am
i going in too deep kind of thing and
you try to extract yourself from it and
and you see your my buddies you know
they went into it and you know they went
into it feet first and
didn't try to come back they you know
they embraced it and got deeper and
deeper then started
using drugs i didn't use drugs then they
started dealing with drugs and you know
when i started seeing all these things
of how it was changing them because they
were a good two three months ahead of me
in the process of transformation if you
will
and i saw where they were hidden i kind
of saw that road map
and i said man i don't want to be like
them
and little by little i just started
pulling away hanging out less and less
with him
and uh to the point that when i got into
high school you know what these guys did
made the transition to high school
probably one semester and then they just
stopped going
and i kept going to high school of
course
and uh and so so they were still my
homeboys they were still in the
neighborhood and um and in a sense it
was great that they were still around
because you know that was kind of like
the protection
that i that i had in the neighborhood
because they knew i was you know
everybody else knew i was
associated with them and so no one there
messed with me because then they had to
respond to these guys and these guys
were very good and you know they respect
the decision i made and it's not like
they harass me and say oh now we're
going to get you now because you left
that they actually said no you go do it
that's uh that's pretty awesome for them
to be able to say that because a lot of
times what you find with kids is
they don't want anyone to
get ahead they don't want anyone to go
further they'd rather just drag them
back down and and i see that in every
actually i see that not just with kids i
see that without with humans human
beings there's a lot of human beings
that when somebody makes a move to try
and elevate and try and go further and
try and do more
people
discourage them instead of encouraging
them yeah it's the
crabs in the bucket crabs
one starts coming out hey come on down
here and you get pulled back down so
that's a real
it's a real testament to those guys that
they actually instead of trying to drag
you back down they tried to lift you up
and help you get out of there
um was there was there anything that
that happened that you saw well how did
you recognize that the path that they
were going down was not the right path
because you know you write it about it
in here here are these guys
you know when you're 13 14 years old
what do you want well you want money you
want girls you know you want a cool car
you want to be popular and here were
these guys well guess what they had
money they had you know they have girls
they had girls so they they kind of had
the stuff that a young 14 15 year old
kid wants
how did you realize that the path that
they were going down was the wrong path
uh very easy we went we went uh cruising
one day we would cruise around stribley
park
and then we got shot at
that wakes you up
i said i don't want to be a statistic
you know we got shot at
and because these guys are dealing and
i must have been dealing in the wrong
area and
they got shot at and i was in there you
know innocent bystander yet but i was
there
and they were caring uh you know and i
said man i don't want to do this
this is not how i want to end up
and you were able to see that luckily
yeah
you know you tell you've got another
story in here that's uh an interesting
story it's a good it's just a good life
lesson you found a wallet with money
tell us that story real quick yeah yeah
we found a um i found a wallet and um
and
i forget how much money it had a
significant had like about six seven
hundred dollars in it cash
and uh but it had a uh it had a
you know an id and everything and
i had an address and everything and um
and
i remember i found it i went home to my
dad you know and i said dad i found this
wallet i said
what's in it
i said there's about 600 bucks in my dad
looks at it first and you know i could
see the temptation he had just as i did
and i think more than anything he just
wanted to teach me a lesson and said you
know
um
if there's an owner here
we ought to try and reach out for him
and and try and do and unfortunately he
lived like in oakland or somewhere
he was visiting uh relatives so we
waited like about a week or two when we
had a weekend and then we drove to
oakland and we found the address and
then i gave it to the guy the guy it was
an older man you know probably in the
60s
and said something about he had sold
something of course i'm not forget what
he did and said he had lost the whole
wallet and he thought he would never see
it he couldn't believe it and uh he gave
me a 20 reward or something like that
and i was happy i said i did something
good and i got 20 bucks out of it so and
i think he gave my dad another 20 for
the gas and stuff yeah but yeah but
teaching that lesson of the doing the
right thing yeah doing the right thing
even though it might
sting your sting your finances a little
bit it's still the right thing to do
that's what your dad would want you to
know
and that was at the same age that was
kind of that same same time frame 14. no
that was a little younger probably a
little younger i was probably about 11
okay still that kind of money yeah as an
11 year old yeah
it's a lot of money yeah
it's a lot of money today yeah for me
600 bucks
14 i probably would have said hey you
know this is a good down payment for my
car that i'm going to get next year or
something but no
i was too young
uh
fast forward a little bit um i started
my freshman year freshman year of high
school at franklin high school at east
stockton at that time frank was one of
the toughest schools in stockton with a
delicate balance of caucasian latino and
african-american students
fast forward i i found refuge in
something i awkwardly called my best
friend
[Music]
math
yes math made me smile it was fun it
remained my strongest subject as i
maintained good grades throughout four
years in high school
you talk about a guy uh mr zendayas
and he told you you were kind of talking
to him about you know your past and your
your history and your ancestors and he
said i think you can find who you really
are in the history of your ancestors
country i know i did jose don't ever be
ashamed of your culture and its
traditions they are what make up your
identity you should be proud of who you
are do you know why
no i answered attentively because you
belong to two countries in two cultures
and that's a wonderful thing not
everyone is as fortunate as you are
so that's an that's a a
kind of a reversal on the pocho thing
where they're telling you don't speak
spanish
like people like your friends hey we're
we we don't speak spanish you were
hiding the fact that you spoke spanish
yes yes and uh and i'll tell you
shortly after
uh
south
my teacher said that
you know i i think i was in
a junior in high school and i'm not sure
if you talk about the
homecoming float but but
it it falls it falls very good uh with
this story
was when um
when i was a a a junior in high school
um you know i started participating in
student government senior i became a
student body president but in junior i
was barely starting so i was part of the
student council and so i went to the
meetings and we were getting ready for
homecoming
and of course every class the
senior class the junior class the
sophomore freshman have a float right
and they they have a homecoming float
and i remember ours we we we wanted to
build a float and everything and um
and they were saying okay but we need a
uh a flatbed and a truck
does anyone have a flatbed and truck and
no one had one because my dad drove a
flatbed in a truck so i knew i had one
right but i wouldn't say anything
because i knew my dad
my dad is not going to lend it to us in
the sense of
drop it off somewhere where we can work
and use it and then uh he'll go pick it
up once we're done he's not like that
he's good he's he's the type that says
oh yeah you guys want sure you can use
it but know you guys come here so i can
keep my eye on my truck and my flatbed
so so so you have to come here and of
course we lived in east stockton
worst part of stockton and we lived in
at the time it was a that two-bedroom
dilapidated rental that we still didn't
own yet and um
actually we did own it by then so we
owned it but it was in the worst part of
stockton and um
and and so
i was embarrassed
to have my classmates come to my house
because i figure you know surely they
live in better houses than this
two-bedroom dilapidated uh piece of junk
that we lived in right but that was our
home
and so i resisted and we had meeting
after meeting
and then it became clear
that the very last meeting they were
going to cancel the junior entry for the
homecoming flow because we didn't have
we didn't have a flatbed or a truck
i finally had to fess up i said you know
i have one
and oh you do great i said but there's a
catch and i said what's that
we got to build a float in my house
in our front yard there at the flatbeds
there my dad won't let take it anywhere
oh don't worry we'll go and what's the
address so i gave him the address and
you know and building the float it's
after class they usually start on a
monday because of the thing is on friday
um
and and so we start on monday and uh and
so
people came
and i remember the first that was kind
of like embarrassed but you know if they
all jumped on the truck they started
working on it then all of a sudden my
mom starts bringing in burritos tacos
agua fresca my dad brings out the
boombox and puts music
my brothers and sisters start helping
out and then the next day word got out
hey there's good food and music party
party
so it got bigger you know by thursday it
was like you know it was overflowing and
not it was great
and um and i remember a a guy a friend
of mine
um comes to me and um
and he looks at me
and he says man i'm so jealous of you
and i said jealous of me and this is a
caucasian guy lived in north side of
stockton good place though he had one of
those uh you know what smoking the
bandit cars oh a trans am trans am
you know he had barely started driving
and he got a new car
and he said he was jealous of me and i
said
i said dude look what you're driving
and you're jealous of me
and he said yeah i said you know i um
sure i have this new car and i live in
north stockton says but you know my
parents are divorced i never see my dad
my mom's a nurse she works long hours i
hardly see her i always come home to an
empty house and the thing you come home
do this
this is what i want
and that's when i
realized
that you know bringing in
both parts of my culture to identify who
jose
is
was the best thing to do
and that's when i stopped being
embarrassed
of my mexican heritage that's when i
embraced it and i said you know with
lots of pride yeah i'm a
mexican-american because i'm able to get
the best of both cultures to define who
jose is today
and uh and so that's you know after
hearing sent mr sanders's uh words
you know i put it to use and i realized
i had this
conclusion that said hey
it's not bad
getting the best things above cultures
of course there's people that get the
worst things above cultures and that
that's real bad uh you know i thought
that's my buddies down the street but
but but you know that's uh that's
another thing it's it's all on what you
focus on too right exactly you know you
you focused on those positive aspects
you know pursued that
took you places yeah
um
you talk about that you did end up being
the like you said the student body uh
president
class president that's pretty cool you
talk about the election in here and
stuff like that um fast forward a little
bit you say one day i heard news a news
brief on the radio that said costa rican
franklin chang diaz the first latino
american astronaut candidate at nasa
makes his dream come true the news
commentator talked in depth about dr
chang diaz's struggles and triumphs in
his quest to become an astronaut
quote franklin chang was born in 1950 in
san jose costa rica he was sent to the
united states after finishing his
secondary education with only 50 to his
name and without knowing a single word
of english
he recounted that all he had was a
suitcase full of aspirations end quote
so you had a little someone to relate to
a little bit you were looking at him
that way exactly well i figured he he
was uh opening the road for others i
said you know once
they
selected the first hispanic american
astronaut
i said well then you know that opens the
door up for me
and uh and and so so yeah so so he was
someone that really kind of
put fuel to my added fuel to my fire of
wanting to become an astronaut because
now i said uh now i know it's possible
because he's living proof then and i re
it resonated so much because you know he
had brown skin like i have he spoke with
an accent like i did and he came from
very humble beginnings just like i did i
said well if he can do it why can't i
and so it empowered me
uh
you got into a bunch of different
universities get done with high school
fast forward a little bit you end up
going to the university of the pacific
which is up in stockton
had a great
engineering program
um and it would allow you to be at home
yeah i saved on room and board
and then i was able to work in the fall
at the cannery during the night shift
i remember you know
the first two months of school was
always tough because it was august
september and then as you get more
seniority you go into october november
in the canneries and then you get laid
off but i i remember uh you know it's
tough uh because
you go to work at and that cannery was
only a block away so i would walk to the
cannery from my house
and i would walk in this big yellow
raincoat because i worked and clean up
from 10 at night to six in the morning
and then i would get home shower
eat something and then my classes start
at eight o'clock at eop finished till
about two three and then did some
homework uh and then fell asleep about
seven and about nine thirty get back up
and go back to work on the grind
underground literally yeah
so but you know it was only a short
period like three months kind of thing
on average it was about three months uh
but you know that helped me
the calorie paid pretty well compared to
field work so they paid very well so
that along with the fact that i didn't
have to pay room and board allowed me to
go to pacific and you know pay
the tuition
my part of the tuition because i got cal
grand pell grant those type of
assistants to get uh
to help pay for the tuition
i gotta cover this one one section cause
we talked about a little bit um
talk about your friends here
years later after drifting apart i would
find out that he did this is carlos he
did
indeed not continue his education he
ended up doing low-skilled work in
low-paying draw jobs
drugs robbed his brother alberto of his
future they found alberto's lifeless
body in his apartment an autopsy
revealed that he died of a drug overdose
probably a result of heroin or cocaine
use as for my neighbor sergio he too did
not have an opportunity to make
something of himself one day years later
as i was getting an award for one of my
projects i received a call from my
mother who told me that the neighbors
stumbled upon his body which was hanging
from a tree in the park to my knowledge
no arrests were made in connection with
his death it remains unclear as to
whether it was a suicide or a homicide
i truly believe my friends were not the
individuals they appeared to be
they were just three little boys
who needed role models in their lives to
steer them in the right direction if
someone would have made them realize the
importance of going to school or infused
them with self-confidence
their destinies would have been very
different
when i received word of their deaths i
felt impotent wondering perhaps
if i could have done something to help
them make the right decisions
you know when you were talking earlier
about um mrs young or ms young
and it's not just educators you know
that have the opportunity to have a huge
impact on people's lives you know
anybody if you're listening to this
right now you can you can help so many
people that you reach out talk to them
try and show them and show them the
right direction i mean it's you don't
have to be in a in a position of
authority to be able to help people and
steer them in the right direction
and it's um you know and and that was
the great differentiator between uh them
and i you look at my parents that were
involved you know they didn't know i
mean that sure they didn't go to pta
meetings and none of that but they were
involved with you know keeping an eye on
us making sure we wouldn't stray and
making sure we were doing well in school
whereas with my friends you know one
for for one of them the one that lives
across the street uh he um you know his
father was never there
he would only come he would come home
like a day or two days before the first
why because that was when the welfare
check arrived
and he would sweet talk his wife you
know take like 90 of the money disappear
for the rest of the month and then give
them 10
to fend for the rest of the month for
the whole family which was terrible and
then uh on the other side the two
brothers uh both the mother and father
were alcoholics
and uh and so it was non you know it was
a dysfunctional family on both sides
there that that didn't help him and and
so
you
when you become
successful and then you hear what
happens to your buddies you can't
you know feel
you know you can't help it but to feel
bad because you say is there anything i
could have done to
have uh
uh help them along the way so that they
wouldn't have end up the way they have
been you know ended up in you know one
odd and another one still selling drugs
on the street and the other one apparent
suicide
and you say you know you do feel
guilty because you say you know maybe i
could have done something
but you know who knows
um
you know speaking of people having him
tell us a little bit about uh senora
bello oh senora beyo
okay
yeah she's uh she was a tough cookie uh
she started off in um
actually in
in
junior high and then when we went to
high school she actually transferred to
the high school so we got a double dose
of her
which i don't know it was good or bad
but the the first dose i got of her
was uh in junior high
and uh and she was the one that
basically remember i told you i started
forgetting my spanish and everything
she's the one that sort of turned that
around and said no
you will learn spanish and you will
learn it in a correct manner you know
and all that stuff as a matter of fact i
went i went to guadalajara she was a
spanish teacher so she set up a trip to
mexico and we went to a blind school and
got boarded there and uh and would spend
like two weeks during easter in in in
mexico and uh and so sham she was tough
as nails uh you know she was a tough
cookie tough grader everything didn't
cut you any slack and um and then in
high school
um she became biology teacher so then i
went to mexico baja california twice
with her again on easter with the
biology kids and we would do
uh plant taxonomy in marine biology uh
in in baja and you know we we would like
make corners of
uh
different quadrants and we would have to
classify every plant in that quadrant so
you get a good uh idea of what kind of
vegetation existed in the baja desert
kind of thing and then we were always
sleeping under a tent and stuff like
that so it was it was uh
it was interesting times there and again
she was very very tough on us but but
you know that's what prepared me for
college man because uh without her
toughness i think i wouldn't have uh had
the the mental toughness to uh get
through physics and chemistry and
calculus and all those engineering
courses yeah you ran into her as you
were starting university and and one of
the things she told you and this is
going back to the book she said you're
all grown up now jose you're about to
turn 18 and embark on embark on your
college career you know i was once young
in college just like you i know the
challenges you're going to face the only
thing i ask of you is not to forget who
you are and where you come from don't
allow anything or anyone to deter you
from your schoolwork
she she was staying on you yeah yeah she
was she was a second mother she was
exactly like a second mother and so she
kept an eye on this
uh you got a cool story in here i gotta
i gotta read this one because it i was i
enjoyed it um
you're checking into your first one of
these classes good morning class i'm
professor andres rodriguez
i will be teaching you physics are there
any questions dr rodriguez was very
short man with silvery white hair who
always seemed to have an unlit cigar
used more like a pacifier in his mouth
or his hand he talked with a very heavy
accent because of the cigar i guess he
was of cuban descent later i would find
out my assumptions to be correct
will a syllabus be handed out asked a
female classmate classmate very
hesitantly syllabus there's no need for
one the curriculum of this class is
going to be something none of you have
ever seen before it's not going to make
any sense without me personally guiding
you throughout the semester let's begin
shall we i shivered with goosebumps when
i heard him speak in what i thought was
an unfriendly tone
looking around the classroom and seeing
all the new faces once again brought me
back to the same feelings i had when i
was in elementary school when i was
trying to figure out what the writing on
the chalkboard meant the only difference
now was that the board was plastered
with symbols and numbers not words in a
foreign language i did not know just 10
minutes into his lecture i was beginning
to think that there was no way i would
ever pass this class the chalkboard was
filling up with one physics formula
after another i might as well have been
staring at egyptian hieroglyph griffix
the professor rodriguez was talking and
writing so quickly that i could barely
keep up i just wrote down everything he
wrote down as fast as i could without
understanding any of it
any questions he asked
no one raised a hand
i took a deep breath and as i exhaled i
dared to raise my hand
professor rodriguez
i really don't understand anything you
just wrote on the board i told him some
of my classmates began to laugh making
me feel like an idiot for raising my
hands
professor rodriguez looked at me smiled
and asked what's your name jose i
responded
well jose the reason why you don't
understand anything
that i wrote
is because it's nonsense it's it's
nonsense it's a joke and if you all look
closely you will see that this was a
lesson in disguised
in disguise everyone became silent
embarrassed by both their own ignorance
and their fair fear of not speaking up
they all seemed to wish they had found
themselves asking for clarification
that's a good trick
you referred back to someone else here
dr jones who said don't ever be left
with any doubts or questions better to
be ignorant for a moment
than for life if you don't understand
something simply ask
that's correct good lesson learned right
there yeah
well you know i figured you know and dr
jones was a uh the director of a program
there at uop university pacific uh the
community involvement program which gave
scholarships to kids from the local area
to attend
the university which is a private
university and you know they paid up to
like 80 percent of your tuition so i
remember
you know
we had like a two-week orientation
before school started and one of the
things this is this was a
african-american tall gentleman dr jones
and um
and he would always call us you know his
kids you know
from the program but he would always say
hey
you need to sit in the front of the
class don't sit in the back why get it
filtered sit in the front ask questions
always do and it says uh and then
he would say
you know jose
um
you know we're giving you a scholarship
right i said yeah i said but how much
are you paying a year i said i have to
still have to come up with about three
thousand dollars
he says okay get your money's worth
and and so that's exactly what i thought
of when dr rodriguez was doing all this
stuff and i was sitting there in front
and writing everything i
understand none of this scrap
don't understand it and i said man i'm
paying three grand i said i'm going to
ask i want my money's worth so i asked
and i said i don't understand this
and that's when he said good i'm glad
you don't because you shouldn't or i
said i just wanna teach you guys the
lessons that because we're gonna go
through a tough course here
if you guys have any questions you ask
them so don't assume because it's only
going to get worse it says it's going to
get worse if you let it pile on
you need to understand the basics so ask
questions
then he started with his lesson yeah i
didn't go to college until i was older
the navy sent me to college when i was
28 years old and i was i would sit right
in the front row and if a professor
talked about something that i didn't
understand i would immediately raise my
hand i don't understand that because i
was i was a grown man you know i didn't
care what the other kids thought i just
wanted to make sure i understood what
they were putting out but that's
something i learned in the seal teams if
you're starting to learn
a tactic or a technique and you're not
getting it and you try and pretend like
you get it it's gonna catch you and it's
gonna bite you it's gonna bite you it's
gonna bite you the same thing being an
astronaut you say you can't pretend you
gotta understand because you know what
there's a little button it could save
you or kill you
uh fast forward a little bit you end up
with a job opportunity this was not only
a job it was an opportunity lawrence
liver livermore national laboratory is a
premier research facility dedicated to
national defense and is funded through
the department of energy it was located
just 40 miles from my home allowing me
to commute to work while i was making
some money too i could not stop thinking
of how i would feel on the first day
walking through those doors so you had
this opportunity to get this job at a at
a lab
that's a huge opportunity yes yes it was
premier national laboratory
r d and uh in defense applications
so uh
and what year did you do that was that
was that did you start interning there
and yes i started interning in 83 and
again in 84
and then i got offered a job in 85
career but i went to my uh master's
degree and then i got hired in 87
full-time
um fast forward a little bit in may of
1985 at the age of 22 i found myself
dressed in a black and orange graduation
gown with my standard issued black cap
ready for college graduation i could
hear my mother's applause as i walked
across the stage to receive my diploma
because it was the loudest
with my degree in hand i stopped to show
her what i'd written on top of my cap
before exiting the stage it read hola
mama
it was a symbol of my gratitude for
everything she had done for me for my
entire life i remember clearly how
everyone turned to look
at her as she rose from her seat
and how her crystalline eyes which were
holding back tears met mine as she blew
me a kiss
big day
yeah very big
you say i wasted no time starting my
career at lawrence livermore national
laboratory in livermore california
um
this is where you decide well
gotta go through the mindset here i came
to the conclusion that for me to
flourish and successfully compete in
this environment i needed to obtain a
postgraduate degree this realization
coupled with the fact that i could not
stop thinking about how i could get into
the nasa astronaut program led me to my
next big decision in life to attend
graduate school
after all dr franklin chang diaz had a
doctorate degree and nasa chose him to
go into space so you're checking these
boxes
end up going to university of uh
california in santa barbara
and this is the first time you got to go
to school where all you had to do was go
to school exactly and then the first
time away from home too okay and uh and
and so uh but yes it was the first time
i i had a full-ride scholarship even
paid for my room and board and
my only job was to go to school
because every other time when i was in
undergraduate i was in the cannery
working in restaurants
work study tutoring doing everything i
was always busy and and here the only
thing i had to do was go to school and
it was so easy luxury it was luxury it
was so easy because i said well what
else do i always felt when i was there
felt so guilty because i said what else
do i need to do i said no you're all
caught up yeah that's luxury i i had
that kind of luxury too so i went to
college then like i said the navy sent
me to college but the navy for some
reason it was an old program i got
commissioned as an officer before i went
to college so then i did two years at a
seal team then they sent me to college
so i was an officer
i didn't have like johnny kim who you
know johnny kim he when he went to
college he had to do rotc and we went to
the same college university but he had
to go to rotc and put on his uniform and
do whatever the navy
requirements were to do yeah me i was
just just going to college i was the
exact same as you just getting a full
pay i would get a paycheck my deal was
even better than yours i think because i
was getting a full navy paycheck yeah
yeah
i was the highest paid college freshman
of all time
it was only and getting your tuition
paid right yeah and my tuition was fully
paid yeah it was really good that's
great but for you going from
where you all your career you were
working at the cannery from 10 o'clock
at night till 6 in the morning and now
you're just there
just focused on school exactly luxury
exactly it was
awesome um
you were kind of
making a transition to another level
meanwhile
this happens going back the book couple
murdered in stockton
news article the article confirmed that
the victims were family members from my
father's side dumbfounded i immediately
called my parents to inform them of the
tragedy but they already knew they were
distraught understandably so i started
thinking my parents live in a
neighborhood similar to the one where my
theo and dia were just murdered
how could i allow my own parents to
continue living in such a place
so you start feeling like you got to do
something on your parents now this is
where you start getting psychological
back on your tests right because you
knew you could just say hey i want to
move you in with me well they're going
to be resistant yeah they're going to be
resistant because they're used to the
old neighborhood all used to the you
know the corner supermarket and those
type of stuff and i knew there was going
to be resistance right but i wanted to
get him out of that neighborhood because
i said you know same thing that happened
to my uncles right could happen to them
and of course they were resistant so go
ahead you go ahead what'd you do you
played a little psychological warfare on
them yeah well you know i had i had just
bought a house myself because i was
working at livermore
so i bought my first uh three bedroom
two bath house in north stockton nice
area
and i was living by myself of course
and and somehow i wanted to get them to
come live with me
and of course
they resisted they said no me this is
our home this is where we belong this is
i said yeah but look what happened to
uh
uncle nat and said no no that's not
gonna happen to us
and uh
finally i said
this this is what i'm gonna do i said
i'm gonna
i'm gonna tell mom that i really need uh
help
with the house cleaning
and uh and and
and
also i'm gonna go to the pharmacy
they'll buy me a few condoms and kind of
just kind of hide them where she could
find them
[Laughter]
and
and i know she was going to clean and
she's going to find them she's probably
not going to say anything to me about
them but i know she's going to have a
conversation with dad
and and and the conversation i figured i
kind of figured i said she's going to
say hey we have to move over there make
sure our kid doesn't make a mistake look
what i found this and and there's a good
catholic you know parents old-fashioned
so uh
so so it worked it worked to the t it
worked the next thing i know is they're
packing their stuff and they're moving
over
so so yes i did use a little bit of
psychology to get them over there
and we've never talked about it since
then she hasn't mentioned it i've never
mentioned it
and uh it just worked yeah
it doesn't work
fast forward a little bit in 1991
you lost your your grandfather
yes um
and that was
i mean your family was close even though
you even though you spent less and less
time in mexico as you got older you
still i mean it was this was like a huge
this is a huge huge impact for you huge
loss yes because i grew up um
as a kid i would spend three months over
there in their house with them growing
up with them you know my parents were
there my siblings were there cousins
would come over and
uh but my grandfather and uh
and grandmother were there and so you
know they were like the
the matriapp and patriarch of the family
kind of thing and and so uh it was a big
loss when when when we lost them
yeah because then
well you're abuela
then shortly thereafter you say this god
must not have wanted to experience such
grief for two long months after my
grandfather's death death her
alzheimer's rapidly accelerated and
robbed her of her last memory was not
long before she reunited with her soul
mate
that's great
and then you lost your your
mother's mother as well right and all
this happened in a pretty short period
sure with a period of about three years
i lost all three of them my my
grandfather on my mother's side
he passed the way of tuberculosis when i
was about two or three years so he got
to know me i don't remember him but he
got to know who i was but uh but yeah in
the short span of those about three
years we lost all all three
uh grandparents
now as this is happening you're you're
still at working at this lab
and while that's going on december 8th
the soviet union falls apart yes
which is has effects
i mean global effects obviously this was
a superpower this was the you know the
the fall of communism and you say this
in the book it was not long after the
fall of the soviet union that ex the
expensive star wars defense programs
such as our own x-ray laser program came
up on the congressional budget's
chopping block yes
so you were working
you were working on things that were
used for defense yes uh the the project
i um i had work
when i got hired as a career employee
because i had worked at the lab already
but when i got hired as a career
employee they gave me a
choice of about three projects
they had um they had a life extension
program where they extended the life of
nuclear warheads and so you worked on on
on how to
evaluate them and certify them so they
can stay longer on the shelf and we call
them good in good operating order that
was one project the other one was
working in the national ignition
facility nif where is nuclear fusion 192
x-ray beams creating nuclear fusion to
create energy which was pretty
interesting but the third one
was uh developing an x-ray laser this is
a nuclear pumped x-ray laser where you
have a nuclear event and you have a
beam of focus x-rays
that would um it would be up deployed up
in space that would um that would be
pointed to any uh oncoming soviet
missiles in the event of a
first strike by the russians when those
missiles go exothermic up in space you
detonate this device you have high
energy x-ray particles that
take out the electronics package and
then they float off harmlessly and so so
out of all these three three projects um
that's the one that interests me because
we had to put it up in space
so i figured you know yeah i gotta learn
how to put hardware up in space i think
nasa would be interested in this not to
mention working on a nuclear x-ray laser
exactly exactly and and we would we
would do our testing in nevada test site
this is when underground nuclear testing
was allowed and you know
whenever they did any nuclear event um
you know the labs uh they would give you
real estate you they would have about 30
experiments in a nuclear event
so they had a whole team that just
dedicated to preparing for a nuclear
event and then they say okay this is
your real estate and you would go down
there and put your package in our case
it's the
the x-ray itself right next to the
bomb and then bunch of diagnostics uh
fiber optics so that when it happens
we're able to measure the flux how
strong those x-rays are and how you know
the density of it and all that so we can
basically measure its performance and
that's what we were doing and uh and so
to me it was great it was uh and yeah
they would throw money at it so money
was never an issue in terms of i need
this i need that and we would uh so it
was fun times until the
soviet union collapsed and then uh
justification for grandiose projects and
justifiably so went away and so that's
why they canceled it yeah you know uh
you described this well when you're
talking about how much money you were
able to utilize you say i credit the
advances in defense shield projects such
as our own x-ray laser as leading to the
downfall of the former soviet union in
short reagan's strategy that's ronald
reagan reagan's strategy worked my own
conclusion leads me to believe that an
effort to keep up with the joneses the
soviet union dedicated the bulk of its
budget to similar programs while paying
less attention to their economy and
internal infrastructure as a result the
ussr created the perfect social and
economic storm that led to unrest and
its eventual downfall that's great
fast forward a little bit one question
started to linger in my mind was how
could we utilize to our advantage the
insight gathered from the work on the
x-ray laser my boss and mentor clint
logan could not have agreed more clint
decided that mammography was the best
way to match both our skills and the
tools we had developed
that's a big leap
we had we also had personal motives for
improving mammography the wife of our
leader in the x-ray laser program had
been diagnosed with breast cancer
and i had just lost a young friend to
the disease on many occasions i served
as an interpreter for my 28 year old
friend and her husband as she underwent
treatment for her cancer i was
astonished to learn that eventually one
in eight women in the united states
acquires this horrible disease
so you guys figured out that some of the
technology that you had used or you had
invented could actually be used in a
positive way for helping detect breast
cancer that's correct
the the area i was in charge of for the
x-ray laser
was evaluating the man-made materials
called aerogels
that that were used as pads for the
x-ray laser and the way i evaluated them
was i would x-ray them and um and create
images to see how homogeneous this
man-made material was so that so that
you could match it because uh you you
had to put about eight eight of these
type of bricks on both sides and you got
to match the interfaces else they lose
energy as it transfers from one
interface to the other and the way i did
it was i i did x-ray imaging but then i
also started uh to fool around with how
x-rays interact with matter and i and i
started writing some code
called uh monte carlo 3d uh
code analysis that that models how the
x-rays uh
react with with matter because some
x-rays go through some get completely
absorbed and some collide with material
and create lower energy x-rays and that
scatter which is noise in the image and
so i modeled all that
and when when the when the um project
got cancelled this was a like a neat
little tool and so clint my boss and i
felt like we had an answer but we didn't
know what the question was
and then when all of a sudden we got
sensitized to breast cancer
and we said i wonder if we can redesign
the mammography machines that create
these images because uh they use film
uh and they develop the film and then
the doctors look at it and light table
well we created a electronic
detector and we designed the x-ray tube
to be more optimal for human tissue uh
diagnosis and uh and we were able to
create the what's called the first
fulfilled digital mammography system for
earlier detection of cancer earlier
because we demonstrated that our images
had much more information content than
the film screen images and then we
opened up a whole new area of study
called computer-aided diagnosis where we
were able to
basically
point out
possible early precursors to breast
cancer which are microcalcifications
steli and circumscribed lesions
asymmetric glandular distortion all
those type of things that will catch the
eye of a radiology and say hey maybe we
should look here and and so we put it in
a smart expert system so that the uh you
not only acquire the images but then you
would put it in super sensitive mode and
then
outline the areas where the radiologists
should focus on and check out and see if
it it's worth going in for a biopsy or
doing something else to the patient so
we were pretty proud i always tell
people
you know when when they ask me what's
your proudest professional moment a lot
of people expect me to say well you know
i flew
on space shuttle discovery and went up
into space international space station
and all that kind of stuff i was a
flight engineer but that's not it it's
it's the fact that you know this device
that we created at lawrence livermore
lab which was a nuclear defense lab yet
we repurposed that technology for
something uh you know that could work
here uh
for for the civilians was developing an
x-ray mammography system that detects
cancer at earlier stages everybody knows
that if you detect cancer at an earlier
stage the greater probability of the
patient
to be saved
occurs and so
i'm convinced that this device has saved
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
lives since its inception back in 97-98
yeah that's i mean that's awesome we
could just end there i guess right
we could just um end there but
the story goes on a little bit it does
in early 1992 when i was 29 years old i
called the national aeronautics and
space administration nasa to ask about
the requirements to become an astronaut
i was hoping to make myself make i was
hoping to make what was a far-fetched
dream for many a reality for myself here
were the requirements
career in a technical field or medicine
check
five years experience check hiring
highly desirable graduate this degree
check nothing prevented me from applying
since i met all their basic requirements
hence i decided to contact nasa much to
my surprise the main operator put me in
contact with astronaut selection office
as part of the first step in the
application process the asp.net
selection office sent me a 12-page
application i promptly filled it out and
mailed it back to nasa
fast forward a little bit
i finally received a letter in the mail
four months after having received the
acknowledgement of my application it
read thank you for your interest in nasa
at the moment there are many qualified
applicants applying for astronaut
positions with nasa unfortunately we
cannot invite you to an interview for
this election cycle we encourage you to
continue applying for future future
selection cycles
so denied
the first of many yeah you got denied um
i've i well a chunk here i gotta bring i
gotta bring adela into the story yes
your wife
um
and you go through a a
really cool story about how you met how
you got together it's in the book it's
great um fast forward a little bit past
that it's adele and i dated for more
than two years before he decided to get
married we were not in any rush to tie
the knot even though we knew we were
meant to be together
six months after we got engaged we
exchanged vows in a traditional catholic
ceremony in lodi california at saint
anne's catholic church
on the way to pick up adela the
limousine got lost and caused her to
arrive 45 minutes late to the wedding
talk about a nervous groom i was
starting to fear she changed her mind
um true story you were sweating it huh i
was sweating bullets maybe she's bailing
on you exactly
uh fast forward a little bit another
year passed so once again i filled out
the 12-page application and waited for
an answer
then after four months of waiting to
hear whether or not i had been accepted
i received another rejection letter with
the words to the effective don't call us
we'll call you
this process of applying and being
rejected repeated itself every year
while i continue to working at the
laboratory whenever i received a
rejection letter from nasa i would
remind myself that there is more than
just one star and one goal in life i had
no other choice but to move forward with
my life adelita's positive influence
helped me develop a healthy balance
between work and family thus i could
safely avoid being consumed with the
notion of trying to become an astronaut
she helped me cope with nasa's
rejections while encouraging me to
sustain my dream
i still wanted to become an astronaut
but i also wanted to live and enjoy my
life
on my way to becoming one a little year
a little over a year and a half into our
marriage adella announced that she was
pregnant with our first child we
experienced our first pregnancy with all
the excitement of first-time parents and
all the nerves too the reason i wanted
to highlight that part obviously having
a baby that's awesome but also
you're going to pursue this dream you're
getting rejected from the stream but you
know you you use this term here
that there's more than one star and more
than one golden knife so even though you
had this goal of becoming an astronaut
you couldn't make that the be-all
end-all i couldn't let it consume right
you know i i used it as a motivator as a
driving force
but i didn't want it to consume my life
you know i wanted to enjoy life
and i and i wanted to uh to say look
it's okay
if you don't reach your goal
because as long as you give it your best
you know it's like my father would
always say say hey you know shoot
for the stars you know but you know the
worst that can happen is you're going to
be on top of the world you know and uh
and so that's
that that's that that's that's what i i
was doing i said you know
the the fact that i was driven to become
an astronaut and was sort of navigating
my career
in sort in in that sort of way
you know had it had my career
on an upward trajectory so it wasn't
like they were competing priorities yeah
well it's like your son they compliment
it it's like your son he wants to be an
astronaut great even if he doesn't get
it he's got his dang phd and a couple
master's degrees he's got all these
doors open exactly exactly but that's an
important thing for people to remember
like you know it's great to have that
big goal but even if you don't make that
goal look at where you got to exactly
and and sometimes
you are the one that changes that
and all goes not the fact that you can't
get there sometimes the fact that you
prepare yourself a certain way opens up
the doors to other opportunities that
you weren't even aware of but all of a
sudden hey i can do this now
go ahead and do it if that's you
if that's what you want to do go ahead
and do it it's okay to change midway as
long as you're going up
uh fast forward a little bit during
adela's pregnancy with our second child
i was traveling extensively to the
former soviet union for lawrence
livermore national laboratory in the u.s
department of energy
as luck would have it i would found out
while i was still in siberia that adela
had gone into labor and given birth to
our baby girl
that's right
fast forward a little bit during one of
my trips to russia i came to an
important conclusion nothing in life
happens or is accomplished purely by
chance goals and dreams are realized
through planning perseverance and hard
work as i was leaning my head against
the window of the state-owned car that
was taking us to our hotel i thought of
how my childhood dream had evolved with
my graduation from college and my work
at one of the most prestigious
laboratories in the united states and
the world
it was because i worked tirelessly
that i could see my transform
transformative effect that my dream had
on shaping each outcome in my life
i also focused on bettering my physical
strength and health because astronauts
are susceptible to rigorous training and
medical exams before blasting off into
space i ran a marathon almost every year
i applied to nasa with the exception of
the year that i was finally selected to
become a member of the astronaut class
little did i know at the time i began
this routine that it would mean i would
end up running 11 marathons
additionally i took up flying lessons at
the tracy municipal airport and obtained
my scuba certification through the
laboratory's
scuba diving club
these were skills i suspected and later
confirmed were indispensable to have for
an astronaut i learned many things
during the time i spent enhancing my
skill sets but above all i learned that
patience really is a virtue it is simply
the best tool to have in one's toolbox
when learning something new
so you're doing everything you can
learning to fly learning a scuba dive
getting in awesome shape running
marathons yeah and i have to um you know
i i got to give more more credit to my
wife adelita
because um i remember um
you know once once the um
i got rejected uh the sixth time
and i had i had um
gotten the rejection letter and i even
scrunched it up and kind of i was in the
bathroom uh shaving when i got and
opened it and i threw in the garbage can
and i missed the can
it fell on the floor and you know i was
i was so pissed off i didn't rage i
didn't pick it up i didn't even pick it
up i said uh heck with it yeah and uh
and my wife i guess was cleaning up that
day and she saw the piece of paper had
it landed in the garbage can she
wouldn't have
picked it up and opened it but it was on
the floor so what's this and she sees
that it's another rejection letter and
she sees it scrunched up so she's
putting two and two she's a pretty
bright girl so so she's she knows i'm
giving up
and uh and and so she goes and she shows
me the the letter says what's this i
said you know
you know they keep saying that over 12
000 people apply for only 10 12
positions i said and
man they've rejected me this is the six
times they rejected me
i said i think i'm going to give up i
said this
enough's enough i said look i got my
graduate degree i'm working at the lab
and all that
and she said so you're gonna settle for
that that what you're gonna settle for
she got you and she not only said that
but then she said
you're going to settle for that and
you're a quitter
that's what got me and she said i'm a
quitter i said no i'm not a quitter
i said look
you're giving up
and and she and she looked at me and she
says you know you better think about
this uh because
i know you she says
if you give up
you're always gonna wonder what if
what if i had put on that put in that
seventh eighth or ninth application and
that's gonna gnaw you from the inside
and you're gonna grow to be a bitter old
man and i don't want to be married to a
bitter old man so you better think about
this
and that's when she got me thinking i
said you know she's
she's right
and so what i did
what i did was that's when i started
doing the things that you just mentioned
there what i did was i i
i i
sat down and i asked myself a
fundamental question i said what do
these guys have
that are getting selected that i don't
have
and that's when i
uh
notice that well they have the same
education they're about the same age
similar experience but then i took a
deeper dive
and that's when i found out
that
they were all pilots so that's when i
invested in myself so i'm going to
become a pilot and then another year i
found out that they were all scuba diver
rated so man i would drive from stockton
to monterey california every weekend i
got basic i got advanced i got scuba
rescue master certified i want to make
sure nasa knew i knew how to scuba dive
so i got those
under my belt and then the opportunity
you know came full circle you said i was
in siberia the opportunity came full
circle
to work with the russians remember
before i was working against the
russians protect us against the russians
now that the soviet union broke up they
were asking for help to take control of
their nuclear stockpile the newly formed
russian federation and uh and no one
wanted to go and help the russians
because from the labs because it was
tough duty you know you had to travel
five six times a year three weeks at a
time
to siberia to siberia of all places you
know you think you take that 13-hour
trip to
moscow
from new york this is after taking a
five-hour trip to uh to from from san
francisco to new york then you take that
13 hour to moscow you think you're there
you still got another six and a half
hour flight into siberia
you know talk about being in the middle
of nowhere and and um no one wanted to
do it but man
i raised my hand i told my boss put me
in coach i'll go i said um and i said
but there's one only one condition i put
he said what's that
he said well
um
i want a one-on-one russian language
instructor because i want to learn
russian
because if i'm going to be doing this
for a long time i think i should know
the language she said yeah we got to
continue education budget knock yourself
out so i so i did that
and i didn't do it because i wanted to
get to know siberia in the middle of
winter
but i did it because i had read in the
newspaper that
the us and russia were going to start
working in the space program together
and so i kind of put two and two
together and i said hey we're going to
be working with the russians up in space
so
this is my differentiator this is what's
going to differentiate me from the 10
000 other at 12 000 other applicants
is that how many are going to be able to
say they go to russia they work with the
russians they happen
to speak russian you know those type of
things and so that's what when finally
things got going and it all all thanks
to you know adelita's prodding of me and
and you know and and and getting to my
pride and saying hey don't be a quitter
kind of thing
uh meanwhile it's not only is she
working psychological warfare on you
she's
a little more after this is back to the
book a little more after our second
child
karina joined our family my wife and i
found out we'd be once again bring a
life into the world
and then halfway through my drive fast
forward halfway through my drive to the
hospital i received a call from my
mother telling me to slow down and drive
carefully as the new baby and its mother
were doing fine
mr missed another birth yeah
believe me i never hear the end of it
especially from the kids
my family and i began to prepare to move
to washington so you got a job offer up
in washington it's the same job from the
lab but working at doe headquarters
department of energy headquarters
i started thinking about the years nasa
denied my admission into their training
program 1992 1993 1994 1995 1996 1997.
um right before we left for washington
to start my start my two-year assignment
nasa finally called offering me the
invitation i've been waiting for my
entire life the person on the phone
informed me that out of more than 4 000
applicants only 300 were selected for a
closer look at their applications out of
those 300 candidates only 100 were
selected to continue on to the final
round of the selection process and i was
one of them
we the finalists were placed in a
conference room where the astronaut
selection manager dwayne ross explained
what we would be doing during our
week-long stay he informed us that we
were the third group of 20 candidates
and that two more groups would be
visiting the johnson space center in the
coming weeks the purpose of our
extensive exams was to help determine
whether we met the medical requirements
for a flight assignment
of the 100 finalists interviewed only 10
to 18 would be selected to become
astronauts
so this time you made it a little closer
a little closer a little closer down to
the final hundred exactly from the
thousands to 100 and they're doing
medical exams to you are you doing any
testing like physical testing yeah yes
yes they do everything from uh from
physical testing to uh psychological
testing aptitude testing and then uh and
then they culminate everything with a
hour-long interview with the whole
selection committee
this i was thinking this has to be the
most highly screened job in the world
this one i can't imagine there's i mean
i guess maybe the president of the
united states although that's
questionable yeah because they get
elected yeah they're getting elected
yeah i i can't imagine a more highly
screened job than being an astronaut
i mean just that's the course and again
there's a lot of good details you put in
the book about this by the book um you
talk about some of the the stories of
the other 19 individuals were truly
amazing some were military test pilots
other were helicopter pilots still
others were medical doctors while the
rest were engineers and scientists
um
eventually dwayne ross called and gave
me the news jose thank you for your
interest in our program unfortunately
you are not selected in this interview
cycle we encourage you to continue close
as we'll be selecting future classes
but wait there's more
dwayne ross continued the phone
conversation said jose if you're
interested we would like to offer you a
position as an engineer here at nasa
johnson space center however this does
not guarantee that you will be
interviewed let alone selected during
the next election cycle if you are
interested in applying to become an
astronaut we suggest you get more
operations experience and we believe you
can gain this type of experience
and knowledge here at nasa so they gave
you a job offer which i was surprised
when i read this but you didn't take it
exactly explain why you didn't take it i
did not take it because
i had just
arrived to washington dc on my change of
station assignment from lawrence
livermore lab the lab has spent about
twenty five thousand dollars moving my
family and i we
had a house rented and everything uh lee
signed with uh and the job was paying
for it but i was working at doe
headquarters um that down in in downtown
washington dc and i had a commitment for
two years
and i couldn't in good conscience you
know after being there a couple of
months say well you know i changed my
mind thanks for spending that 25k i'm
going to houston now i didn't want to
burn any bridges or i well not not that
it was burning bridges but more than it
wasn't the right thing to do you know i
hadn't made a commitment and uh and i
wanted to uh fulfill it so i i gave uh
dwayne ross a call and i told him that i
respectfully i have to decline the offer
but i gave him my story this is this is
why i i feel i cannot do it and uh and
he understood uh you know i figured he
i'm never gonna hear from him again
because uh i turned him down but uh lo
and behold the following you know couple
years they they call again
1992 once again renewed my application
by now i felt i could fill it out with
my eyes closed
for the second time i was one of the
hundred last hundred finalists just like
the time before these lucky 100 were
invited in groups of 20 to spend a week
go through a series of medical and
psychological exams interviews and tours
the various training facilities
when nasa decides to let the hundred
individuals know whether they've been
selected or not the calls to all 100
people occur within the span of a few
hours it was rumored that if a candidate
picked up the phone and the johnson
space center director
who was george abbey at the time was on
the other end it would be good news
however if it was the
astronaut selection manager dwayne ross
or any other interview panel member one
could almost guarantee it would be a
thanks but try again type a call true to
the rumor
when i received the call from duane it
was to tell me that i had been seriously
considered but it was not my year
he then went on to suggest that again
i consider an engineering position at
johnson space center
so then you go and talk to your wife
adelita
say may i talk to you for a moment she
said of course something wrong he said i
want to talk about something really
important i have thought about the whole
situation with nasa a lot but before we
finalize our decision i want to confirm
something with you we're getting ready
to head back to california and i'm
probably going to get a promotion and a
nice raise when i report back to work at
the laboratory that said i think it is
best job i think it's best for me to
turn down the job offer with nasa
because they offered you another job yes
houston is hot and muggy anyways we'll
have less money to spend and adelina
interrupted me honey if moving to
houston and working for nasa as an
engineer is what it will take to for you
to make your dream come true then we'll
move to houston in a heartbeat boom yeah
and that was the deal yeah so now you
now you accept the job
um
at nasa as an engineer as an engineer
not as an astronaut it's still really
cool yeah i'm i'm in engineering yeah
and low man on the totem pole um
on january 21st 2003 we welcomed our
fifth child second baby boy into the
world
a few days earlier on january 16 2003 at
9 39 a.m the space shuttle columbia took
off for its scheduled mission with seven
astronauts on board
columbia was scheduled to land back on
earth on february 1st 2003 at 7 15 a.m
the orbital maneuvering system engines
were turned on for a de-orbit burn
this burn allows the atmosphere to
capture the space shuttle columbia and
thus begin its re-entry to earth
within minutes the temperature sensor on
the left wings breaks began to show an
increase in temperature it was the first
serious indication that something was
wrong
at 7 59 a.m
the last words from the space shuttle
columbia were transmitted understood uh
but
three minutes later columbia broke apart
raining a field of debris across the
northwest parts of texas and louisiana
you use a term in here
um
it's it's normalization of deviation
and and i started thinking about that
term
and what it means and how
how it obviously have impacted this
horrible incident with losing the space
shuttle columbia
but it seems like something that we a
mistake that we something that we can do
in our own lives this normalization of
deviation can you talk about that a
little bit what caused the accident and
what how that idea of normalization of
deviation played into it sure well but
by that time i had been there for three
years at nasa and i worked myself up to
branch chief of the materials and
processes branch and this is the
engineering
branch that does the
failure analysis
and finds out root causes of failures of
materials
and and so
when the uh space shuttle disintegrated
up in northwest texas louisiana
um
you know my group was one of the first
groups that were out there picking up
the pieces we were the ones that
put the hanger in florida and outline
the shuttle and brought every piece and
forensic evidence and put it all
together and did the testing
in terms of the materials to find out
where the breach occurred and once we
were pretty certain that that's where
the breach occurred which is on the left
wing leading edge which is a
reinforced carbon-carbon substrate hard
substrate
we we went to southwest research in san
antonio and we built a
full-size wing of the shuttle and then
we looked at the image analysis and saw
pieces of foam that fell from the tank
insulation that big orange tank center
tank that fell and hit
the left wing leading edge we found out
we calculated the speed the size of it
and we replicated that experiment at
southwest research through a air gun
fire that those pieces of foam to the
wing leading edge and recreated
basically the
the cracks that occurred because that's
the material that helps uh on re-entry
you're up to about 2700 degrees
and you know um
the aluminum structure inside it's
aluminum melts at about 900 degrees or
so so if there's a crack in there it's
gonna get in there and it's gonna
affect the
structural integrity of the wing and
that's what caused it to snap and create
that catastrophic failure and pieces all
over
northwest texas
occurred and and and so um so
during all this time you know the um
the president uh had the columbia
accident investigation
board or uh board uh formed and since i
was the the branch chief i gave a lot of
briefings of the findings uh you know
there's a whole teams hundreds of
hundreds of people that contributed
certainly not me myself but i i was one
of the spokespeople in terms of telling
the science part of it uh the results of
how what we measured and all that and
and and so i got a lot of face time with
a lot of people at nasa and they ended
up you know they started looking at me
and trusting me and all that that that
that uh you know we came up with the
with the story of how what was the root
cause of the failure which is of course
the piece of foam that they did and um
but shortly thereafter the following
year they have a selection
um a selection of astronauts and i'm
again one of the finalists and this time
when i sit down across the 18
people that are there you know i know
more than half of them through this
accident investigation board
uh franklin chang diaz is sitting there
he's one of the guys so it's kind of
like i come home to family now before it
was a complete set of strangers
and now everybody knew me i knew them
and i think my work spoke for itself and
uh and i think that's what finally did
it but unfortunately you know we had to
lose a space shuttle for that to occur i
mean then it's kind of like a
bittersweet moment for me
with the normalization of deviation
explain that that term it's like
where something goes a little bit wrong
and you go you know what it's not it's
not that big of a deal it's like a
normalization of of issues yes what
happened was um in in in that sense
we've had debris fall off the tank
in the past
um
and our engineers
would cry wolf they would say hey
something happened here and we don't
know what's going to happen on re-entry
and you know they would do that three or
four times and you did see pieces but it
didn't hit anything
and so everybody so wait so they weren't
really crying wolf they were actually
saying this could cause a problem but
nothing ever bad happened exactly
nothing ever bad happened but but but
the fact is the fact is that when they
cried wolf when it really did happen
because they had normalized
that occurrence
then the powers to be didn't put enough
weight behind it to say let's stop and
let's
go out do an eva and let's inspect the
wing leading edge where it hit because
that's that should have been the proper
response
all right and uh and that didn't happen
and so that's why i call it
normalization of deviation yeah it seems
like well the way i thought about that
after reading it was thinking about just
us as human beings in our lives and we
make a little mistake but we get away
with it right and then you me or you go
you do something that you know you
shouldn't do
but you get away with it you don't you
know you go and eat a donut well you
know that's just one doughnut
then you look up in a month and you've
had a bunch of doughnuts and all of a
sudden you got a problem and you got
five pounds on you right
so we got to be careful of that that
idea um discipline what a travesty that
was um
to get to that point you were just
talking about in the fall of 2003 the
selection process for the next wave of
hopeful astronauts opened once again i
turn my updated application
the fact that i work for nasa did not
guarantee my acceptance and they made
sure i understood that when i accepted
the job at nasa in 2001.
working at this is this is a beautiful
point although i was anxious for the
selection process to begin i can
honestly say i was content and at peace
with where i was in life if i was not
selected to travel into space i would
accept that since i was happy working
with nasa working at nasa made me
realize that space flight involves tens
of thousands of people and that every
single person is as important to the
success of the mission as the seven crew
members aboard the space shuttle
so you realize that and that was a
you know yeah i worked in the trenches
with everybody and so i had the
opportunity to appreciate
what um
with the dedication of everybody because
you know when i went to work there
you know i took a 10
pay cut from
lawrence livermore lab because i made
too much money at the lab so so uh you
know that that was one part of my
hesitation of accepting the job that my
wife convinced me and said hey don't
worry about it we'll make it happen and
and so
so so so from that perspective you know
that's
the the the point i'm getting at is that
the people that work there can make more
money
elsewhere
but they love their job and they're
doing everything possible and it only
took me
uh you know
when i s when i was part of the whole
process of the accident investigation
and i saw the dedication of everybody
and then uh in previous to that when we
were preparing for launches i saw the
dedication of people during their normal
activities and so a lot of people always
told me when i got selected in 2004 and
said are you crazy i said the
space shuttle just disintegrated
last year and you just got selected
aren't you afraid
and i said no it says because i know
these people i know there
is tens of thousands that we depend on
but i know they're here because they
want to be here
you know they're gonna dot their eyes
and cross their t's because these are
dedicated folks i mean i had first hand
working with them in the trenches uh and
i know their dedication so i was a peace
of mind when i
jumped into my space shuttle i was i was
more than confident things were going to
turn out good
uh
when going for going fast forward a
little bit when the whole interview
process ended i along with 99 other
aspiring individuals had nothing to do
but wait about four months later i
received a telephone call while working
in my office frankly i was prepared for
the response that i knew all too well
however this particular call did not
come from the center director or the
astronaut selection manager dwayne ross
it came from a senior manager colonel
bob cabana who is in charge of the
flight crew operations directorate
and who was an astronaut himself
i knew that if the center director was
calling it was sure to be good news when
somebody on the recommendation board
like bob was calling i really did not
know what to think
i was puzzled he started the
conversation with the usual salutations
and then went on to ask if i thought i
was replaceable as head of the materials
and process branch my response was
genuine when i told them that i thought
everyone was replaceable
and that all along i had taken upon
myself the responsibility to mentor and
train folks to be ready to take my place
good he said
how would you like to come work for the
astronaut office
i quickly realized i had been accepted
my whole body went numb the second i
heard the good news i did not know how i
was going to be able to hold the
telephone without dropping it a nervous
laugh escaped my lips but no words came
out as i listened to bob continue
speaking now jose you cannot tell
anybody beyond your immediate family
about this
because it will be announced at a press
conference on may 6 at nasa headquarters
in washington d.c
warned of the voice at the other end of
the line i agreed said goodbye and hung
up i did not tell anyone anything i
still had four hours before i could go
home from work and i could not think of
anything else but telling my beautiful
wife adelita
she had to be the first to hear the good
news followed by my kids and then my
parents the 10-minute drive home seemed
to last an eternity adelina adelita
guess what our opportunity has come
finally i got accepted i'm going to be
an astronaut
there it is
yeah
how many so how many total times did you
apply uh it was the 12th time the 12th
time yeah
11 straight years of rejection exactly
and the 12th time there you are 12 times
the charm
uh nasa press conference took place i
still had to keep the big news a secret
from almost everyone at 11 a.m my fellow
astronauts and i were brought
face-to-face with the press we were all
nervous and careful
of our every step as we walk single file
line just like my siblings and i had
when we entered the
house after coming home from school when
the cameras and microphones were
directed us i remember thinking to
myself i'm an astronaut not a famous
movie star my palms were sweaty and
there was nothing i could do about it we
were introduced one by one satcher
cassidy arnold dutton and hernandez and
cassidy's a seal and he was in your
group huh yes he was my classmate good
friend of mine
oh that's awesome
um
our first big training assignment
involved traveling to the naval air
station in pensacola florida once there
we spent six weeks going to ground
school being taught water survival
techniques learning how to co-pilot the
t-34 airplanes ground school involved
not only learning the basic principles
of flight but also putting those
principles to work in high fidelity
flight simulators probably the most
interesting activity during the six week
training program was the one where we
went on submersible device that
simulated the fuselage of a helicopter
this device is actually known as the
helo dunker
so you when you get picked up and when
you get picked up for the program you're
still not an astronaut you have to make
it through how long is that training
program two years this astronaut
candidate program
it's two years you go through a lot of
academics
you
go through the learning the systems of
the space shuttle 18 you know a typical
airline has about
eight or nine subsystems an airline
plane the space shuttle has
and you have to learn each one of them
you have written tests on each one of
them then you got single system trainers
so you master each one of them then you
got multi-system trainers where they
start cross-pollinating the systems and
how one system affects the other and
then you've got the high fidelity motion
based simulator where then a pickup crew
of four of you are in the cockpit and
they throw everything but the kitchen
sink at you and you've got uh you know
it's either an ascent run or is it an
orbit operations or it's a landing and
but they'll fail things for you and you
got to figure it out and you got to pass
all that every friday there's a test uh
it's like being in finals week for two
continuous years i mean pretty intense
but i mean i'm sure it's similar to like
for seal training as well that that you
have to go through all these things but
it's not only you know it's academic
mental physical uh the whole combination
of things where they really stress you
and
and you know that's how they figure out
you've got the right stuff if you're
able to survive that then
then you move on you get your wings and
now you're eligible for a flight
assignment how many people
that get selected to enter the pipeline
the two-year pipeline how many people
don't make it
you know it's very rare that a person
doesn't make it because they've been
filtered so filtered they've been
filtered uh you know the book says four
thousand that was when it first began
but when i was in uh and that's my
twelfth try we were up to twelve
thousand uh this past time selection run
they were up to eighteen thousand
applicants so they filter it pretty well
uh including the psychologists that
filter everything that you know when
they uh when they select you you know
that they have a high probability 99.9
that you're going to make it because
you've been filtered you've been tested
aptitude testing psychological testing
stress testing so they have a feeling
that you're gonna make it so but you
still gotta do it yeah no that's the the
impression that i got when reading this
also talking to johnny kim and
is that if you get selected they've
already they've already figured out
because the thing that's interesting to
me is you talk about you're putting
these failures failure situations over
and over again
and you know there's people that panic
in those situations there's people that
lose their cool in those situations
there's people that don't know how to
handle themselves that's why i think
it's interesting like just because you
became a pilot well if you panic if you
become a pilot you learn to get control
of your emotions and not panic and same
thing with scuba diving right if you
panic while you're scuba diving if
something goes wrong you're going to
have some real problems with some
problems so those are things that
they're looking at your application
going well he's a pilot so we know he's
at least going to be able to detach from
his emotions though oh he's a scuba
diver so when things get interesting
not claustrophobic so there's they have
all these things in line so that you can
you have a very high percentage chance
obviously you could have some kind of a
medical anomaly or something but
that is the i do i'm curious i'm sure
people will give me feedback if there's
a more highly screened job than an
astronaut and i know you just gave some
props to seal training i could tell you
uh
there's all kinds of knuckle draggers
and see what i'm probably cased case in
point you know exhibit a
uh that
that what we go through is more about
just being wet cold and miserable but um
so
uh
fast forward a little bit once our two
years of training and testing were over
we held a small graduation ceremony at
space center houston kent rommel the
chief of the astronaut office said a few
words before presenting each of us with
a silver pin
with the astronaut logo on it this is a
symbol used for astronauts who have yet
to travel into space
a gold pin symbolizes that an astronaut
has already flown on a mission so you
get the new guy symbol exactly
but it's an important symbol because
you're now
eligible you're in the pool of eligible
astronauts
when they select a new crew you could be
one selected whereas before you were
just an ascan astronaut candidate you
couldn't be selected to train for a real
mission now you you're eligible to get
assigned and meanwhile you talk about
that you have
so once you once you become an astronaut
and you're not an ass can anymore i'm
using that
that's a good one
once you're not an ass candidate you're
an actual astronaut
then you spend 20 of your time sort of
focused on training and simulations and
getting ready to fly a mission eighty
percent of your time is work yes and
your job was a cape crusader exactly
tell us about the cape crusader yeah we
call them c squareds uh because that's
cave crusader two c's c squares um it
was great i was a great job um you know
two weeks before launch
you and
three other buddies a group of four
astronauts you know you fly over from
houston to florida where the birds at
the shuttle
and you start prepping the vehicle for
launch so you start prepping the inside
and doing testing with ground control
and everything so you get everything
ready for the mission
and then um and then uh
the day of the launch
then uh if you're the lead
c-squared
then you get the number seven on you
know how you see all those white tech
quote technicians the number seven is
always the astronaut there's always
there's always an astronaut there
because he's the one that buckles the
their fellow astronauts into uh the
cockpit of every uh every mission and
unfortunately your face is the last one
they see before they go up into space
yeah and so so uh and i did that a
couple of times um you know i for four
like uh
for like two years i participated as a c
squared but during the last part of
those two years i got i was the lead uh
c-squared because that's how it usually
happens is the lead guy first you're the
new guy
and then you're the middle guy and then
uh you're the expert and then you get
assigned so you move out and then so the
middle guy becomes the expert and so
that's kind of like a fifo first in
first out kind of thing uh you become an
expert by lieu of your experience but
then you get assigned to a mission and
so that's what happened to me i
participated about seven launches during
those two years and the last two i was
the lead c square and uh it's great
because you go there two weeks before
you're you're in crew quarters uh so you
you spend time with the astronauts you
know they arrive about a week before the
launch so you spend time with them uh
before they're going to go off to their
mission you're
debriefing them on the status of the
bird and how things are going and all
that kind of thing any questions they
have and then uh the day of the launch
you know you go out there with them and
you're out there strapping them in and
getting them ready and then
it's pretty neat because you're also
part of the rescue crew
so you're in the closest the absolute
closest part you can be
to watch the launch
i mean you feel where where you
physically where are you you could feel
uh one of the bunkers you can feel the
heat you can feel the heat of the
exhaust you know because it's so close i
mean it's dangerously close so you're
sitting there in a bunker yeah with uh
with a bulletproof glass or something
right exactly you can watch how far away
you think you are from it ah let's see i
would say about a mile mile and a half
maybe and you can still feel the heel oh
yeah you can feel you can feel the heat
and uh but it's just amazing i mean that
launch that you go out i mean it's it's
it's it's it's crazy when you see it
take off and you can't believe that big
heavy piece of metal is going to take
off and yeah there it goes i was going
through navy boot camp so this is
september
sometime i think it was either september
and october of 1990 and i'm in orlando
florida going to boot camp and i'm
standing at parade rest out on the out
on the grinder and there was a space
shuttle launch and we said you know sat
there and watched this thing go up in
space yeah yeah it's a quite an uh image
isn't it even from that distance yeah
very cool
um
meanwhile
going back to the look my wife
adelita had just opened up a restaurant
in houston
down the street from the johnson space
center on the corner of saturn and
gemini in the clear lake area so she's
just getting after it going and opening
up in a restaurant she always had a
dream of opening up a restaurant you
know she grew up in the same
socioeconomic conditions i did her
parents are from mexico and uh she was
born over there because she was born in
november okay christmas elsie would have
been born here but she was born over
there and uh so she came up with the
same upbringing i did and um and so her
dream was always
to uh own and operate a restaurant and
so uh once i got situated i got selected
i i was jogging one day and i found this
place that was for rent and i took her i
said how about here it's only a couple
blocks from the restaurant so we opened
it it's called it was called uh tierra
luna grill
and tira luna means earth moon but my
buddies
uh astronaut buddies didn't call it
earth moon because terra is also dirt
so they call it dirt moon grill so let's
go dirt moon grill eat and so that would
be the hangout for the astronaut studio
but i remember the very first time i um
i went out there as a c-squared
uh
adelita had just opened up the
restaurant
and so imagine this
you know we get up at three in the
morning
um and so i go and prep the vehicle
uh and then i go and and and astronauts
arrive about six o'clock
so so we we then tuck them in into this
into the space shuttle you know close
the hatch secure everything do our leak
checks everything works out we go out to
the muster area for the rescue area
and um and we see them blast off and
that was my first
that was the first shuttle i seen in
person launch and i was that close
and so it takes off
it takes off and
this is about 9 30 now so as soon as it
takes off there's nothing for us to do
so what do we do we hop on the
on on the t38 jet
that's right there
that we had flown in from houston and we
go back to houston ellington field
and ellington fields about
six miles from johnson space center so
and it's still mid days i said well i'm
not going to go home now i said i could
go back to the office so i'm driving to
the office but on the way is adelitas
restaurants i want to go get some lunch
get some dirt moves yeah let's go go
dirt moon grill and get some lunch and
plus i want to tell delita
the whole exciting
uh what i saw oh cause that was your
first one
so i'm over there so excited and you
know because i flew on the t-38 over the
gulf over the pond
landed so there i am telling adelita you
know how i flew the t-38 jet we're back
how i saw the space shuttle you know to
think that the space shuttle i was on
the space shuttle at three four five in
the morning and uh now it's up in space
and my buddies are up in space and she's
just kind of like what looking at her
watch and
so she wasn't even paying attention to
it
yeah exactly it's kind of like the
teacher from charlie brown right and uh
and and so i i i kind of
i say hey what's wrong i said oh
nothing i said well you know maybe you
can help me i said sure what can i do i
said do you have about an hour hour and
a half to spare i said yeah i probably
can i'm not no one's expecting me back
in the office so yeah i got an hour and
a half spare so like my dishwasher
didn't show up today
would you mind you know this is the busy
time the busy time is coming it's close
to lunch would you mind washing the
dishes
for me for just about an hour and a half
just till the rush goes over
and i'm still in my blue flight suit get
some yeah so i put on an apron and i i
you know roll up my sleeves and there i
am you know spraying beans and rice off
the plates and cause it's a mexican
restaurant you know and all this stuff
and she walks in and and i said
you know i tell her i can't believe it
it's at three in the morning i was in
the most
sophisticated piece of machinery
that humans could ever had made
and then
i was flying a t-38 jet across the pond
the gulf of mexico i landed it here
and what am i doing right now
i'm washing freaking beans off of that
plate
and she just looked at me i said but
you're doing a damn good job
the most overqualified dishwasher of all
time
probably the only uh probably the only
uh dishwasher ever to take a t38 jet to
work exactly and that's so so that's uh
you know it humbles gotta stay humble
the family humbles you the family yeah
and i'll tell you the other story that
you you i didn't tell you also that has
to do with the blue suit too
is um
which one was it my fourth daughter my
fourth daughter i mean the fourth in
line third daughter the youngest
daughter of them all
i remember when i got selected as an
astronaut well they gave you that blue
flight suit right
and because it has your velcro name tag
here and everything the nasa meet paul
logo and all american flag and all that
kind of stuff it looks pretty cool so
they give it to you so i bring it home
you know the first day they gave it to
me so yeah i want to try it on make sure
it's the right size they gave me and all
that so i put it on my wife has a full
dress mirror in the bedroom right
so there i am i'm putting it on you know
it has zippers galore everywhere right
zippers here zippers here zipper series
efforts here zippers on the legs and
zippers down the pant legs and all that
stuff so i'm playing with them getting
to know and then you know posing kind of
doing my best you know
hero shots kind of thing you know
hey i'll be true i was kind of you know
i was you know flexing kind of thing you
know all that kind of stuff
and then my my five-year-old daughter
walks into the bedroom the door's open
and and and she's kind of like yeah look
she was younger she was four years old
because i remember she
she still had her little you know kind
of
the maggie uh
yeah and she's looking at me like this
and tilting her head one way tilting her
head the other way
and i said ah she's gonna see me in my
blue flight so she heard you know
because we've been talking that i became
an astronaut and this that she's going
to go and she's going to hug me and say
hey papi i'm so happy you're an
astronaut and all that that's
what the reaction i think she's going to
happen when she sees me i didn't get
embarrassed that she saw me posing
because yeah she's little if it was my
wife i would have been a little intense
but she was a little kid so i so you
know i said hey mikhail how you doing
and she's
still turning her head
and then in between the pacifier and
everything you know she points at me
and she says
you look like papa smirk
so from then on it became whenever i
want to look for my suit i said where's
the smurfs
because when it's in the laundry or
something i said where's my smurf suit i
need my spur suit and so you got to stay
humble the family will give you help
[Music]
exactly
uh you going forward a little bit you
say everything seemed to be going
according to how i ideally imagine it
would when i was a kid working in the
ruts and groves of the fields though my
life seemed in order there was a certain
sense of emptiness
there was no reason for me to feel this
way since i had everything i'd ever wish
for out of nowhere i heard my mother's
voice saying what is the purpose of
having goals in life working hard for
them and achieving them if you cannot
share them with others
even though i was sharing this moment
with my family and friends i was still
not completely enjoying the moment or
myself
this was particularly true after
coming to stockton to speak at a school
i felt the excitement my visit generated
when i shared my experiences with the
elementary school children but then when
i returned to houston for training it
felt as if i had never visited stockton
something was missing something that
would give
that would that could give continuity to
my visits during this time my friends
and colleagues had called or emailed me
to tell me what a positive impact my
selection as an astronaut had made in
the stockton community that was when the
idea hit me why not start a foundation
that capitalizes on my role as an
astronaut and allows me to inspire kids
to do well in school
so therefore
um
angel piquan am i saying that right
and patty tovar two of my great friends
friends helped me start the legal
framework work for establishing a
non-profit organization called the jose
hernandez reaching for the stars
foundation angel and patty put together
a board and helped me define the
foundation's mission which is to inspire
kids to dream the impossible and to
emphasize that through education
anything is possible
and you say i do not believe in just
pointing out a problem and expecting the
government to solve it on its own
i would like to think that this is the
responsibility of every person in the
united states and that the private
sector and foundations such as mine
should take some ownership for resolving
this issue and that issue is getting
more kids into
specifically stem stem science
technology engineering and math fields
yes
so you got that foundation started we'll
talk a little bit about that at the end
sure um
you asked to see me sir i said as soon
as i walked into mr steve lindsay's
office mr lindsay was an active
astronaut and the chief of the astronaut
office he was a very intelligent and
slender all-american air force man whose
grade hair
grade haired head stored a half
centuries expert experience and
knowledge yes jose please have a seat he
told me politely
i've called to inform you that you have
been selected to form part of the crew
of the upcoming
sts-128 mission in about 15 months you
will be at the international space
station we will announce the names of
the rest of the crew members at our all
hands meeting
this was something that i had longed for
and wished for my entire life it was the
preamble to my dream come true my dream
had been actualized i found myself one
step closer a significant step closer to
flying into space
i thought finally my time has come
the big day yes
you got told it was a go
fast forward a little bit
here we go as the launch date approached
it became harder to sleep i tossed and
turned for hours until i was finally
able to sleep soundly part of the reason
i was not able to sleep was because i
kept thinking about what could possibly
go wrong during the mission what if
something fails what will happen to my
family how will my wife kids and parents
handle it those thoughts disrupted my
tranquility luckily though as the date
approached there was no time left to
worry about anything but the mission our
crew
began adapting to a new schedule going
to bed at 8am and waking up at 4pm we
were forced to shift our sleep cycle
because those were the hours we would be
working on the international space
station
the closer we got to launch date the
more lucid our mission objectives became
our first objective was to transport a
new crew member nicole stott to the iss
and then return
home with another astronaut tim copra
who had already spent more than two
months in space second we had to conduct
three spacewalks to replace one of the
station's ammonia-filled tanks last we
had to make an attack take an
italian-built portable laboratory called
the multi-purpose logistics module
affectionately called leonardo
we also needed to bring back to earth
about a ton of equipment and waste no
longer needed aboard the iss with all
that said we had only 13 days to
complete our three mission objectives so
you got a schedule heading up there a
heavy schedule
they're not playing around they're going
to get their money's worth out of you
exactly
um
fast forward a little bit and i'm going
again look you got to get the book if
you want to get the details of what's
going on and it's
it's really fascinating to hear you know
what you're thinking about as this
progresses and
all the things that you're working on on
the things that you do as a team look
i'm skipping over a bunch of stuff
but what you do as a team to kind of
come together as a team the seven person
group that you're gonna be working
together all this really incredible
stuff uh again i'm not doing an audio
book here buy the book if you wanna know
what happens yeah there's a lot you're
skipping oh yeah of course um
um so i am skipping to this part here we
arrived at the launch pad
and entered the elevator to go up the
192 foot level where we had access to
the shuttle's hatch a walkway allowed us
to approach the white room that was next
to the hatch it was in this white room
where we put on the last of our gear
before entering the shuttle and getting
strapped in by the closeout crew
one by one we were called in to take our
seats
fast forward members of the closeout
crew exited the shuttle the hatch was
shut and closed it was then that the
closeout crew performed a cabin leak
check and then disassembled the white
room to clear the launch pad
during the last hour before launch i sat
strapped to my seat on the flight deck
a million different thoughts rushed
through my mind
fast forward a little bit suddenly i
heard the countdown reach the nine
minute hold
that is when the final systems checked
are conducted by the launch control
center it was almost time make your
final adjustments and prepare for
takeoff we heard
cabin revision complete manual's ready
seconds before launch the bottom of the
launch pad was sprayed with water in an
effort to cushion the noise and
vibration as a result of the power
dissipated by both the three main
the three shuttle main engines and the
two solid rocket boosters
everything was going to plan
until
pete nicole nicolenko the launch
director informed us that the weather
conditions were
unfavorable
50 minutes later our mission was aborted
due to local thunderstorms in the
florida skies
so close
so close ouch
a few hours later a new date and time
was announced for
the discovery launch wednesday august 26
2009 this was a 48-hour slip the mission
management team who had set the new
launch date obviously did not share our
optimism about the weather improving
within 24 hours
as we woke up on wednesday we found out
that it was not going to happen then
either
we discovered a defective fuel control
valve which is being replaced at the
moment we pushed back the launch date
again for 11 59 on
friday august 28 2009
nasa informed us
that reminds me of you know when you're
on an airplane at the on the tarmac and
first it gets delayed and then it gets
delayed again and all of a sudden they
go hey we found a maintenance problem
next thing you know flight gets canceled
or deboarding keyboard and that was a
legitimate there was a chance that you
wouldn't if this got rolled a little bit
more there would be no launch at all
that's right
so this the whole thing is in jeopardy
yeah
but was that faulty fuel valve would
would that have been a problem
that's um you know the thing that we
don't know you know we're kind of lucky
the weather was bad yeah because uh you
don't know if that faulty fuel valve
would have acted up during that
launch right
and uh and once we shut things off and
then started back up we got that
indication
and we replaced it so you know it could
have been that the weather saved us
could have
been just never know
luckily on friday we once again found
ourselves sitting inside discovery ready
for takeoff with only two and a half
hours to go i knew it was only a matter
of time before
a button was pushed and we would be well
on our way into space
the nasa team in houston was confident
that the third time was indeed a charm
suddenly in the blink of an eye the
countdown clock was set into motion
after having reached the 9 minute hold
we could hear the countdown nine minutes
five seconds four
three
two
we closed our helmet visors as we heard
the three main engines light up shortly
thereafter we felt the gentle vibrations
of the engines about two seconds later
as the countdown reached zero the noise
level increased in a magnitude and the
vibrations grew more violent the two
solid motors attached to the side of the
external tanks it had ignited just as i
thought the whole shuttle was going to
shake apart or fall to one side i felt a
lot of pressure on my back
i heard zero
take off
through the corner of my eye could see
the tower staying behind as we lifted
off we were on our way immediately the
muscle memory of our training
simulations took over i quickly focused
on my job as mission specialist two
which was to execute the role of a
flight engineer i began reading off the
predetermined milestones to our
commander and pilot while monitoring the
screens and gauges in the front and
above me to ensure none of them would
deviate from their expected readings the
most dynamic parts of our mission were
blast off and the subsequent eight and a
half minute flight into space during the
latter we went from resting on the
launch pad to orbiting our planet at
more than seventeen thousand five 500
miles an hour at an altitude of some 280
miles
two and a half minutes into our launch
the two solid rocket boosters separated
and fell to the ocean about 200 miles
northeast of the kennedy space center
after the initial two and a half minutes
the next six minutes became quieter and
the ride became a lot smoother when we
reached 8 minutes and 30 seconds into
the flight we had reached the main
engine cutoff this basically meant that
we had reached our top speed of 1000 or
seventeen thousand five hundred miles an
hour and it turned off our main engines
the next step was for us to monitor the
separation of the external tank which
was feeding our three
main engines the external tank typically
ends up so high that it does not survive
re-entry into the atmosphere and thus
disintegrates into pieces before falling
harmlessly back into the ocean the
shuttle usually possesses enough energy
to continue upward and when appropriate
begins orbiting the planet soon after
this happened to us we approached we
reached a microgravity environment and
began floating in space high above the
earth our mission was well on its way
when that thing starts to rumble well
how's that feel where that thing starts
to go
you know i'll be honest with you jacob
is is that you know if there was any
piece of fear during this whole process
of being an astronaut
i would have to say it's probably the
first three seconds
of when you reach zero
and you feel the three engines light up
and then you feel the two solid rocket
motors
turn on come to life
all of a sudden things are vibrating and
uh you know this is the type of stuff
that can't be simulated here on earth
and so you don't know what to expect and
yeah at that moment you
you you know the first thing i said is
jose what did you get yourself
yeah but then shortly after that as the
book indicates you know muscle memory
takes over and you know we've done a
bunch of simulated motion-based ascent
runs as a crew and uh and so
i
focus on to my test sec at hand you know
i had the best seat in the house because
i'm sitting a little aft of the two
pilots the commander
and the pilot kevin ford and my my
commander cj sterkow
great marine pilot and uh and and kevin
ford is an air force pilot and i'm
sitting a little behind them in the
middle so i get the panoramic view
but you know of course i have to hawk
all the 10 screens of both pilots so
that if anything goes
off nominal i peel off with the person
that owns the system and me as the
flight engineer you know i'm the one
that's basically quarterbacking what the
problem is diagnosing what we need to be
doing and
between
the pilot and i we solve or try to
minimize its effect while the other
pilot flies the nominal portion of the
mission and so uh so but nothing
happened it was the best similar i
always
tell my commander this was the best
simulation run ever because nothing
happened everything
occurred as it was supposed to occur
unlike our simulations where they throw
the kitchen sink at us
and and so uh but man you know words
can't describe
those eight and a half minutes of
powered flight because you know you
start off like the greatest disneyland
ride ever
and uh and then as you as you move up
the two and a half minutes when the
solid rocket boosters pop off
it becomes smooth a more smooth smoother
ride more quiet ride but you start
accelerating more and you start feeling
the pressure against your chest so you
end up feeling about
up to uh it goes almost up to three g's
of force
right on your chest and that's three g's
is about um
what is it uh three people that weigh
exactly like you on top of you that's
how three g's feel so i at at the mark
of eight and a half minutes you're ready
for this to be over you're ready for
main engine cutoff miko and and because
when that happens you stop accelerating
so that 500 pound gorilla disappears and
now you're kind of loosely goosey in
your seat but you got your seat belt on
but now you're in a microgravity
environment orbiting earth
once every 90 minutes on a continuous
basis 17 000 miles an hour 17 500 miles
an hour
you're traveling but because now you're
not accelerating you don't feel the
g-forces so now you're it's kind of like
being on a plane going 500 miles an hour
you don't feel that uh you only feel the
take-off kind of thing uh and and so
yeah so you know it's it's it's crazy
because you know when you look out the
window
and you see the us you go off and do
something for 20 minutes and now you're
flying over china or australia or over
europe kind of thing it's it's uh it's
the craziest uh
feeling i've ever had it says wow this
is uh this is a good way to travel
yeah that's uh as you're describing that
both in writing and then you talking
you're sitting on a freaking bomb
on a bomb that's what you're sitting on
all that stuff just wants to explode and
it's just control yeah it's a little bit
it's a controlled detonation yeah that's
what you're on the top of that and
you're on top of that
puppy um
once you get into space you go into this
this schedule of all this stuff that you
that you've gotta do and right
you you you detail it in the book it's
it's a great read one thing you you had
a little case of nausea while you're up
there a little bit like seasickness yeah
they call it sas
space adaptation sickness so it makes
you feel a little nauseated uh you know
one of my crew members lost their
cookies
i didn't uh i actually lost them on the
way back which is a 1g
re-adaptation uh but but but uh on the
way up uh one of my crewmates did uh get
get sick to the point they you know they
had to throw up but uh but it goes away
you know after a day or so that feeling
it's kind of like
being in the back of a bus and going up
a mountain curves and all that you kind
of feel a little carsick nauseated but
then it goes but then it goes away yeah
um fast forward a little bit day three
we're about 183 meters away from the
international space station our shuttle
began the 360 degree rotation for the
purpose of being photographed using high
resolution photography and video by the
station space station crew
they take pictures from the spa from the
space station of the space shuttle just
to make sure there's no damage on
liftoff
but that's got to be pretty weird to be
up in space and you're 183 yards away
from this other big chunk of metal
traveling at 1700
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah but that was one of the
new um
procedures as a result of the columbia
accident that we put is that uh we would
you know before we dock to the station
we would reach a certain distance stop
do a holding pattern there and then we
would do a maneuver where where we would
show our belly to them and as we're
showing our belly they're filming
everything of course uh downlinking it
to the engineers down on the ground
looking at that leading
wing edge and any other type of things
that other damage that could have
occurred to your tps system which is
your thermal protection system which is
the underbelly and the wing leading edge
of the of the shuttle
that we uh we investigate inspect
uh
the the docking you call it a collision
in here it's like it says a collision or
soft dock that's got to be crazy too
you're aiming the space shuttle at that
thing and you're going to like connect
yeah you're going to connect and i'll
tell you um it was even kind of crazy
a little bit more crazy for us than
normal because um
you know nothing real big happened in
terms of malfunctions during our mission
except this one thing
and um the shuttle
has um built-in jets to maneuver in
space including the ohms engine orbital
maneuvering system those are the big
engines that we fire to slow down so
that we can get back into the atmosphere
but we don't use those for docking we
have built-in jets that are on the nose
the tail
and near the wings of the um of the
shuttle and they fire to maneuver in
space
and um and we have two types we have the
regular
called rcs jets reaction control system
jets and then we got the verniers which
are the fine-tuning jets they're kind of
like the small ones they're one-tenth
the thrust the big ones
and so when as you as you're docking to
the station
you use the rough ones the rcs
and then as you get in
you switch to the
fine ones so you could do the fine
tuning so that you can dock because the
uh the
pilot the both pilots have are at the
controls i'm at the station as flight
engineer giving them uh and they're
using they have a target so they have a
camera system so they're looking at at
the camera one's looking outside and
then i'm looking at the screens giving
them speed uh i i giving them a distance
uh
and and then also whether they're in
plane or out of plane in terms of i give
them numbers to indicate that if if it's
all zeros it means they're coming in
plane and then if it's a different
number i give them so that they can
provide some type of correction and
they're doing all that
but as i mentioned as you get closer you
switch over to the fine jets which move
you very little
but our fine jets fail
so there's no vernier jets so we got the
big
honking uh rough you know coarse jets
that we can do so now our our our
commander cj sterkow the good marine he
is
you know when you
when you move a a vernier jet you know
you move very little but when you move
when you do the regular rcs jets it goes
like that right and so what he has to do
is he's looking at the
at the approaching speed
he's looking at the
at this but now he has to time his
firing so that when he fires it
as it goes
it hits at the middle
and uh and we practice that during uh
during because we practice everything so
we practice so we've done that before
but the fact is that you know that was
probably one of the uh uh pucker moments
we had in saying geez oh we would get
this right because if not you you you
could damage the docking mechanism you
could get stuck or or you could just
bounce off kind of thing so
but but he did well i mean like the good
marine pilot that he is
yeah uh
you get docked um sleeping up there that
sounds like it's a strange experience
you gotta like tie yourself into a
sleeping bag basically exactly you what
happens is you got to
tie the four corners of your sleeping
bag to structure and then you gotta
slide in
and you zip yourself up there's the uh
the the sleeping bags have holes so you
can stick your hands out
and the weirdest thing is you don't need
a pillow
because your
your head doesn't bob right there's no
weight yeah
your hands whatever position your hands
are that's how you're sleeping you know
i got these cool frankenstein pictures
of my crewmates
like that because that's the way you
sleep i mean whatever position you're in
you're gonna sleep in that position but
i'll tell you it was the weirdest
feeling going to sleep the first and
second night
but after that
i said you know this is the best
sleep you can
ever you know no tempur-pedic
mattress
nothing mattress mac in houston can sell
with respect to his mattresses uh this
is the best sleep you can get because
you got no pressure
you have no pressure points what's the
what's the how many hours would you get
to sleep for you get to sleep up it was
on the average about six hours and 10
minutes somewhere
that's what my uh my sleep thing said
about six hours 10 minutes
um day eight
you got this in here the eighth day of
the mission was very special one for me
jose the interview is set up and ready
you have four minutes and 30 seconds to
do it i was told i was delighted to hear
carlos a famous mexican reporter who had
been following my story for some time
truth be told i was terrified at the
thought of knowing that millions of
people in latin america were going to
see my interview
it was only after i returned and
conversed with him that i found out he
felt the same way this was a historic
interview as it was the first live
interview from space conducted in
spanish
the minutes went by so quickly that i
felt my time was up just as i was
getting started we we talked about the
view of mexico from space including the
attractive coast of the state of
quintana roo and the yucatan peninsula
we also spoke about my inability to
detect
borders that divide earth into countries
there are no borders from what i can see
up here our world leaders should see how
beautiful and precious our world looks
from this perspective i said to the
reporter
one world from up there huh yeah you
know um interesting story there jackal
with respect to what happened after that
you know i i basically uh
said you know the the most beautiful
thing there was two things that two
takeaways the first one
had to do with what you just mentioned
is that i was able to see canada the us
and mexico but what struck me in awe
and that's so beautiful is that
we couldn't i couldn't differentiate
where canada ended the us began or where
the u.s ended in mexico began
and and this aha moment i said man i had
to go out of this world
to come to this conclusion
that down there
we're all just one
because borders
are
human-made
concepts designed to separate us
and how sad because from my perspective
we're just
one down there
and it'd be great to have our
world leaders
give
to give them this opportunity because
i'll assure you our world will be much
better
now the thing that
what the news got out of all this when i
came home and you can look up the new
york times
and the l.a times came up with the
headlines
saying a mexican
american astronaut
wants to open borders
that's what they got out of this my
story
i say good grief
yeah but yeah everything has to be
politicized
they want to get people to click on
those headlines exactly and uh and which
i found it so sad because i said yeah i
wasn't even talking about that i was
just talking about the concept that
we're just one down there
you know and uh but somehow from there
they got the fact that i wanted to
remove all borders and get let everybody
come into the u.s
what can i say that's the uh that's the
media for you yeah
um
so again i'm gonna i'm gonna skip
forward you gotta read the book to get
some of these details about the flight
day 14 on this day we made our final
preparations to begin the deorbit
procedures this included closing our
payload bay doors and once again putting
on the orange les suits for the entry
phase of our flight
observing the beauty of the earth from
space was something i have not been able
to put into words well not in a way
where i have felt i was able to truly do
justice to this spectacular view i felt
goosebumps knowing that few people have
had the privilege of looking at our
planet
from my perspective i marveled at the
blueness of the oceans the whiteness of
the clouds at one point i was able to
make out the lights of some cities i can
see san francisco mexico city and
houston i managed to steal a few more
moments for myself while i while the
rest of the crew worked without anyone
noticing i made my way over to a corner
and pulled out the crucifix that adelida
gave me and said a prayer
let us lord
see your love in the world forgive us
for our wrong doings give us faith to
trust in your goodness forgive our
ignorance and weakness
give us the power to continue
trusting wholeheartedly and show us what
we can do for peace on earth amen
and you guys end up spending an extra
time up in space an extra day yes the
weather was not cooperating in florida
and flight rules are
that if it's uh
if it's more than uh
a couple of rotations around the earth
and you still can't land you postpone it
for
24 hours and if it's still bad weather
you go to your second preferred landing
site and so you got your second
preferred landing site which was
california yes edwards air force base
not too far from here yeah yeah and
which was
kind of nice because you were going to
land in california but also your family
wasn't going to be there yes yes my
family was waiting for me in
in florida because they were they wanted
to witness the landing in person and of
course uh once it got canceled they
didn't have enough time uh to fly and
meet us over here at edwards air force
base but i kind of liked it because you
know it's california and i'm landing at
edwards air force base i call it poetic
justice
because it's uh it's some 80 miles from
chino ontario where i used to pick
strawberries
so
here i am coming in
with a uh
you know in a nasa space suit a good old
american flag on my shoulder coming in
as a u.s nasa astronaut uh when you know
40 years ago i was
you know over there picking
uh strawberries
man
uh
this landing was no joke too i mean
you describe it here as each minute past
the distance between our shuttle and
earth lesson the planet also grew bigger
in size before our very eyes which meant
that we were getting closer to home in
my mind i was counting down the minutes
until we were safely on the ground our
landing point at edwards air force base
in california was a mere dot on our map
as as discovery darted across the sky at
high speed i saw in our instruments that
we broke mach 25
at that point we were traveling at
slightly more than 25 times the speed of
sound i could feel the buffeting of the
shuttle with the atmosphere and i
noticed an orange glow outside our
windows we were definitely in the
atmosphere now i noticed gravity gravity
slowly taking its effect as the weight
of my helmet attached my orange les
became heavier at about 26 000 feet we
broke through the cloud layer and i had
a good view of the ground both below us
and in front of us by now the shuttle
had the characteristics of an airplane
as the aerodynamic surface controls were
responding to the commander's input the
shuttle slowed down to normal airplane
speeds and behave more like a glider
would since it did not have an active
propulsion system during the landing
phase of the flight
this of course meant we only had one
opportunity to land it our commander and
pilot had practiced these landings
hundreds if not thousands of times in
simulators and in actual approaches
utilizing one of the two planes that
have been modified to be able to fly the
shuttle's landing profile
at 400 feet with the gear already armed
our pilot kevin activated the gear down
command
this poised the wheels of the shuttle
for contact with the surface of the
pavement at edwards air force base in
preparation for landing the landing
strip was ready in no time
soon thereafter
we were literally racing down the
landing strip until the parachute
deployed and the pedal brake slowly
brought us to a complete
[Music]
stop the opening of the shuttle doors
reminded me of the times i had to open
them to welcome back the returning
astronauts however this time i would be
welcomed
and indeed we were welcome back i was
told by one of my class colleagues
as he unbuckled my seat we patted one
another on the back once i was able to
stand up
i exited the shuttle with a smile on my
face the seven of us crew members were
beyond ecstatic everything went as
planned our mission commander began to
congratulate us and said we did it we
couldn't have asked for a better team
all of us
had to spend an extra day on the base
before we were able to go home as i
waited for the moment when i could go
back to houston i could not fathom the
irony of my dream going into space space
both beginning in and concluding in the
golden state
as a boy i dreamed of becoming an
astronaut as i picked crops as a man i
would exit the shuttle as an astronaut
on a landing strip located just a few
miles from where i grew up picking
strawberries it was poetic really
there was truly
this delightful symmetry to my life that
helped me realize the importance of
remaining humble
and remembering where i came from
epic um
and and the story goes on here you go on
to talk about retiring from nasa uh
going into the corporate world as an
executive
you you let me tell you a little bit
about the retirement uh part of it it
was a hard decision to
to
uh go about and uh and deciding jacob
because um i'll tell you
i remember when we got back when we got
back from um
from space shortly thereafter they
announced the retirement of the shuttle
fleet
so they were going to retire the whole
space shuttle program i think they had
four or five flights more manifested and
then after that program is over
and uh but they had them all assigned so
because they assigned about four or five
crews ahead because they're training
already for the next flight or they're
going to get ready to train and so i
knew
you know since i just got back i'm in
the back of the line right
of the queue so i knew i wasn't going to
get assigned another mission
but then
i was one of the prime candidates uh
what we were going to be flying is uh
when we were flying already was with the
russians all right we paid the russians
50 million dollars per seat and we go up
on the soyuz um and and they'll take you
to the station uh
so so i was one of the prime candidates
because of my background of traveling to
russia for five years and knowing
russian and all that and i thought i i
thought okay well i'm going to be one of
the first ones i'm down for that i'll do
that
but then you read the fine print and um
you read the fine print and and what you
don't realize is that the
training in russia it's a three-year
training program
and so 80 of the time you're in russia
and it's not continuous it's like you go
six weeks you come back one week you go
eight weeks come back one week you know
12 weeks come back two weeks kind of
thing like that for three years
and
and then you go up for six months
continuous and then when you come back
you go on the road for six months
continuous uh divulging everything all
the science you did
so
and all in all it was a four-year ordeal
where you were going to be gone about
ninety percent of the time eighty-five
ninety percent of the time from home
and i got five kids
my oldest at that time was 15 years old
and
the youngest was about seven years old
and so i did the math and i said you
know all these kids i'm gonna miss
you know they're you know they're in boy
scouts there's softball baseball proms
high school graduation
uh you know this 15 year old's gonna be
a 19 year old already off in college
at least i assume he's gonna go to
college i'm not gonna be around to find
out or to guide him and so so quickly i
think my hispanic culture kind of kicked
in and and and i gave a lot of weight
to
the family
and i'll tell you man it was the hardest
decision in my life because
you know we just got through reading
what it took to get here
to get there to get assigned and to be
part of nasa and after flying only once
here i am considering chucking it all
away
because i could fly again
but you know i kind of just thought
about it prayed about it
uh
i didn't want to talk to my wife about
it because i know her answer is we can
do it we can do it i didn't want her to
convince me i said you know this is
uh you know there's there's a fine line
where you know you do it for what you
want to do for you
and then that fine line of being more
egotistical than
you know not considering
other folks
and uh and so you know i thought about
it thought about it and finally i said
you know i think the best thing for me
to do is to just leave give someone else
an opportunity you can fly i mean i
could stay and not fly but i'm taking up
a building
i said that's not fair either i said i
it's probably best for me to leave and
give someone else
it says give the johnnies
of the world a chance johnny can the
seat exactly give give the johnny kim's
of the world an opportunity so they can
fly
and so it was the hardest decision uh
that i i that i could have uh
made but you know i look back at it and
i look at where all my kids are at in
life right now all college graduates my
youngest seven-year-old is a freshman in
mechanical engineering at uc merced uh
you know the phd my three girls have
their bachelor's one of them is
finishing her masters in may and uh one
of them is a big uh influencer in uh
in in
in tick tock you know okay
and if you guys really want to have a
laugh
uh because i come on a lot she films me
a lot uh go at the vanessa hernandez
okay and you'll see you'll see her
you'll see me make a fool of myself
but you know anything from my daughter
you know but you're not doing tech talk
dances are you or are you oh you got to
look at it man all kinds of stuff i'm
telling you all kinds of things she
graduated from so you truly will do
anything for your family exactly
tick-tock dance she graduated from
loyola marymount and she works for a
vitamin pharmaceutical company uh near
la jolla maramon so she still lives in
the la area and uh but she's been she's
been you know doing social media stuff
and uh she's gonna start her own podcast
too that they already contacted her
before the start but but she's been
doing good on tick-tock i mean she she
represents a few companies and tick-tock
and she's i think she's banking more on
than she is in her day job you know and
working a lot less so but but yeah but
it's those decisions you know that i
think uh
uh you know i i really uh
you know i look back at it and i don't
regret it because i look at how my kids
turned out because i've been here for
them and i continue to be there for them
and uh and so i think i made the right
decision
yeah well that's uh definitely a a
difficult decision to make i know i was
in the military and that's the the
decision that military individuals like
myself have to make at some point are
you gonna keep going you gonna keep
going on deployment yeah you're talking
about missing all those things i missed
all those things i missed everything you
know and eventually had to say
uh i owe it i owe a little something
i've done what i can for the country i
owe something to the family that i've
left behind for months and months and
months and months at a time so
that's i agree the
that's you know people ask me what's the
toughest decision you ever made in the
military and they think i'm going to say
some tactical situation or some mission
it was like no
deciding to get out was the thing that i
thought the most about and it was the
hardest decision i had to make and then
people tell me well didn't you know
you've gone in why did you go in the
first place i said no that the rules
were changed midstream i mean they
decided to retire the space shuttle
fleet i mean i i thought the space
shuttle fleet you know they told me it
was going to be going on for another 10
20 years and i would have got another
three four flights under my belt but
when you take that away and they say hey
the only game in town now is with the
russians for the next 10 years
i figured you know i think it's time for
me to leave then if you guys change the
rules and i value my family as much as i
do and i think they need me at this
point in their life pre-teenage teenage
years i mean that's the most important
part of the kids growing up stage and
you know i think it's a job where both
parents have to be present and you know
thumbs on on them to make sure that they
just like my parents were with me make
sure that they're you know on the
straight and arrow go heading in the
right direction yeah yeah
um
and then you ended up getting a job in
in the in the corporate world
um you end up running for congress yes
yes
i get i get i get uh
i i i get uh
convinced well they convinced me to run
for congress and it was uh it yeah
that's a long story in itself too but
but it was at the urging of uh president
obama you know he
he
sought me out not once not twice but
three times and when
you get sought out the third time and
your commander in chief
straight out tells you
the first two times he says you ought to
consider it
and the third time he said he he told me
and i quote i'm gonna make the ask
i said please run for congress in
california
so when the commander-in-chief stares at
you
in the eyes and says run for congress
what you do you salute the flag
and so so i did you know i gave it my
best we
we were they didn't put me in my
district because my district is i'm a
democrat so my district is a heavy
democrat but we already had someone
there
that had seniority so why
why knock off a
seniority level democrat and put a
freshman there
why not go after a
republican seat so they sent me next
door
at the time they were plus 11 in
registration
and we lost by one and a half points
so we almost made it but
but it left a bad taste in my mouth you
know i can't imagine the taste that left
in your mouth
yeah politics you know it's kind of like
you know i just don't have you know i
have the stomach for a lot of things but
but when it's stuff like that it's kind
of like there's no rules and you know
there's scruple i mean it's just like no
ethics at all and i said you know that's
not me
so one shot was enough at that one i
think for now never say never
never say never jackal but uh but but
for now it's it's it's uh i think i'm
doing okay where i'm at right now
yeah um
now you need to go around you know you
do speaking events right now and and
you talk about that a little bit here
and i want to close out you know we've
covered some of the book but i wanted to
close out the book with this this little
section where you talk about what you
talk about you say i share with everyone
the magical recipe for success that i
applied to my own life
it is a recipe that i learned from my
parents and i also shared here with you
one
identify your goal in life
two realize and understand how far you
are away from that goal
three develop a road map to get there
don't skip steps
four get yourself a good education
consistent with your goal
five develop a good work ethic and put
your heart into reaching your goal
six and this is the one you added you
mentioned earlier exemplify perseverance
never give up on your dream and remember
that it is the journey not the
destination that is of most importance
then you continue on these are not the
steps to become an astronaut
these are the steps to harvest your own
stars
the recipe works for anyone in any part
of the world
and trust me it's infallible
so that's what you go around talking
about yes i'm a motivational speaker and
i i share my story
and uh also that recipe
and and talk and talk about what what
you know what it took to get there and
like a good engineer i try to
try to
um
basically capture it in a formula type
of environment like the uh
recipe that you just read off there i
also give a three element strategy that
says hey to reach your goal you know
you've gotta
you've gotta and this i learned
afterwards right is is is you got to
know what the minimum requirements are
once you define your goal is natural
tendency and 99.9 percent of us
get this
right is you ask yourself uh what are
the requirements to get there you know
you want to be a doctor you know you got
to go to medical pre-med medical school
and pass the boards lawyer pre-law law
pass the bar
astronaut you know you gotta go to the
stem field get graduate degree uh four
or five years experience and then start
applying
so that's the first one everybody gets
that one you know it's it's no the
requirement second one is
emulate successful people
that you want to aspire to be
like in other words
you know ask yourself
what do they have that i don't have
you know if you want to be a ceo study a
ceo and study find out how they got
there you want to be an astronaut study
an astronaut i mean that's what i did
after my sixth
failure remember
i compared myself i found out they were
all pilots so what did i do i invested
in myself i became a pilot then i found
out they were all scuba certified what
did i do
i invested in myself and became scuba
certified
the third stage of that
of that uh of of of that strategy
is is
you gotta create a differentiator
in other words differentiate yourself
from differentiate yourself from the
competition
you know at the time you know it was
from 4 000 and went up to 12 000 uh that
i had to differentiate myself so it was
no accident
that i took that job going to russia it
was strategic
in my career i said it's going to help
my career obviously but it's also going
to help me over here because you know i
just read that the us
and the newly formed russia signed an
agreement to build what was going to be
the international space station so it
didn't take a rocket scientist to figure
out even though i am one no you are one
even though i am one but i didn't take a
rocket scientist figure out we were
going to be working with the russians
so my great differentiator is during
these next five years in this project i
traveled more than 25 times to the
russian siberian countryside and worked
with the russians
and all this
you know helped me
get the upper hand
on the other
14 12 000 applicants because very few of
them could save
or claim similar experience
than what i had and at least that got me
in the door to start getting interviewed
and then the rest i would just sell
myself
so yeah so that's the three element
strategy that i add up up to that
and so that's what so that's what you're
doing now now you got your foundation
the reaching the stars foundation
yes at astrojh.org
if you go look at it astrojh.org
you'll see everything we do in the
central valley where we try to motivate
kids to get interested in stem careers
science technology engineering math we
have a summer academy at the university
of pacific same school i went to where
we have uh
kids from the 7th to 12th grade
in the
six week summer program where we uh
basically inundate them with stem
concepts fun stem concepts that they can
take back to their
school and uh and and and get a head
start in their uh math and science
courses they're going to see the
following year so we we basically expose
them to those concepts that we know
they're good we know what the core
curriculum is so we expose them to those
ideas in a fun experimental experiential
way uh so that when they go back to
school they say oh yeah i've seen this
it's my fact i know the experiment and
so they do very well and so we we do
that
for them and then uh and then we we also
have a
science blast where we get uh over a
thousand kids in the fifth grade
to uh
in a one-day
exploratorium type of environment where
we have all kinds of hands-on
experiments we have people from lawrence
livermore lab from google from apple
come
and they talk about what their careers
are and basically uh you know expose
them to stem careers and why we do that
at fifth grade because that's the age
when i decided i want to be an astronaut
so i think if it's good enough for me
it's good enough for them and then
whatever monies we have left over
because we we sort of uh have on a year
to year budget whatever moneys we have
left over we give scholarships to the
kids
so
no that's awesome i know um
the you know that's what america needs
america needs kids that are growing up
that want to
learn stem yes we need lots of engineers
and scientists yeah that's that's the
that's the competition for the future
chinese and chinese are all india are
kicking our butts and producing more
scientists and engineers than we are and
that's going to cost us
10 years from now 20 years from now it's
going to cost us if we don't if we don't
rectify the situation yeah i know i i
can find myself sometimes being pretty
down on the
academia right for people that are going
to the debt and they're they're
borrowing all this money to go to
college but they get a degree that
doesn't really give them a job you know
they'll get a degree in something that
doesn't you can't go you don't have a
skill set i mean engineering is a skill
set it's something that you learn
something you know how to do so the fact
that you're doing that that program
is
leaning kids in the right direction for
something that can actually
provide not only them with a good career
but also provides america with something
that we desperately need and we're
definitely going to need even more in
the future
and on top of all that
you also have a winery right well well
first of all you know
all that is just volunteer you know we i
get i get nothing out of it right except
but i feel good but you still have to
put it together yeah yeah yeah it's a
time sink yeah right right unpaid time
saving what i'm saying on top of all the
time you spend doing that and all the
time you spend speaking you also
but before the winery i also have a uh a
engineering consulting business first
yeah i have a tira luna engineering uh
where i do aerospace consulting if you
know for example i helped mexico uh buy
and launch three communication
satellites from boeing corporation that
was a 1.2 billion dollar purchase for
mexico and uh and they hired me because
uh the under secretary of communications
was uh he he himself admitted he says
look i'm an economist a politician
economist i know diddley squad about
satellites and here we are spending 1.2
billion dollars uh can you help us so i
worked on a neat project for about four
years uh helping them launch three
communication satellites so they uh it's
they can have internet throughout all of
mexico any population over 5 000 the
government put a dish so they would have
connectivity to the outside world which
is uh which is pretty neat so i do that
um you know i've i've also helped a
university build a cubesat small
satellite 10 by 10 by 10 centimeters and
with nasa we launched it for free for
them and they became the first
university in mexico to have built
design and keyword operated their own
satellite from space
so we did that for them i'm helping i
also created an a aerospace curriculum
for them
working with a three campus university
in northern mexico and that's tira luna
engineering
which by the way if you go to the dot
com store there tier luna engineering
dot com you can actually get the book
reaching for the stars you can get the
children's book there and you can buy an
amazon and quite frankly you could
probably buy it a little cheaper but if
you buy it through our website you'll
guarantee that i can sign it and
dedicate whatever you want me to say on
it i'll dedicate it and the proceeds go
to my foundation so that's why i want to
make sure and clarify that you know i
think it's like 30 bucks for the book or
something like that but it's signed by
me and uh and we send it off and uh and
so you can do that at
terelunaengineering.com and then as as
as as um
as if that wasn't enough i kind of come
full circle
and uh my wife wanted a back to the
field exactly my no my wife wanted a
home out in the country
and so
about five years ago you know when we
were well down established back in
stockton
i started looking for some property
because yeah you know happy wife happy
life right and so i started looking for
the
property so that we can build a house
out in the country because she wants to
live in a country and i said yeah okay
i'm i'm a country boy too
and man i saw the price and they were
expensive
and then i ran into this
20-acre vineyard
and
it was income producing and it was only
about twice as much as an empty three
acre lot in the country
i said man that's a no-brainer i'm gonna
i'm gonna become a farmer
back to the fields and i became a a
great uh farmer and the reason why i was
so
into it was because first of all i know
how to pick grapes but that's the only
thing i know i don't know diddly squat
about about running a vineyard but you
know who does
my dad my dad's worked in there all his
life and so i told pops that's what we
call him pops i told pops hey if i buy
this vineyard would you teach me how to
run the vineyard you say yeah son so
these past five years with him you know
he's 84 strong man it's good you know
field work background he's strong and
healthy you know this best five years i
spent with him quality time he's
teaching me uh you know what to
fertilize how to fertilize uh when water
and you know he gets up on the tractor
and he plows and mows and all kinds of
stuff that he does
helping me with the with the vineyard
and and and and we sell all the grapes
to a winery that makes uh
a champion well sparkling wine can call
it champagne here in california
sparkling wine that's right and it's um
it's it's it's corbell so we sell it to
them but then they make the mistake of
one day inviting me to
see their processes
and i saw how they engineered mine
starts going to work exactly i started
looking at the process of how they make
wine
and you know my favorite phrase is hey
this ain't rocket science
i can make this
i can make this probably more
efficiently too exactly exactly and so
so i started you know a couple years ago
started working with my own formulations
and making my own wine and finally i
settled on three
concoctions that that we have and uh and
so i started my company again everything
under tierra luna members tier luna
engineering remember my wife's
restaurant it was called
tira luna grill yeah when we came to
california and i opened up tierra luna
engineering i handed a dollar to my wife
so what's this for i said i'm buying
your naming rights
of your now defunct restaurant because
uh you're over here you closed it down
here here's here's the dollar i'm going
to call it luna engineering and then
after that
i open uh another company called tira
luna sellers that's with a c c e l l a r
s sellers dot com com and then uh that's
where i i sell my wine now uh this is
the first year we came out with it it's
a direct to uh consumer uh
and hopefully we'll end up being in
stores and stuff later on when we are
production but we're right now we're
sort of just getting it out there and
getting it known and uh and we have you
know we have three varieties you know we
have a sauvignon blanc which has my
grapes so if you want to drink wine from
my vineyard
you'll see that the sauvignon blanc is
the one to go and then i buy grapes from
lodi
and i make a red zinfandel which is also
good and then i buy grapes from uh from
the napa area and i make a red blend
that's a combination of uh of merlot uh
tempranillo syrah and petite syrah so i
call that the red blend and then i named
them after constellations because the
the the company is called tier luna
sellers but like the first one i ever
made was with my grapes so i call it uh
new star which is nova stella okay uh in
in in latin nova stella and then uh and
then the uh zinfandel i call it stella z
you know z constellation
and then uh and then the
red blend i call it stella roja which is
a red star right and so uh so so but but
yeah you know it's it's a great uh it's
a great activity i enjoy it you know
it's kind of like another challenge that
you start from nothing and you create
the labels you create the formulation
and all of a sudden you got this nice
bottle and say you know i'm the one that
created this this is so cool
and so
so so it's just enjoyable i i love doing
this i love doing this yeah that's uh
man you're just getting warmed up i
guess i guess so yes yes and and then
and then to top it off you know
my son
my youngest son i told you he was going
to uc merced right
um he got accepted to university pacific
and he got accepted to uc santa barbara
amongst other schools but the three he
liked was uc santa barbara
um
university pacific and uc merced
and i was certain he was going to pick
pacific or santa barbara but he picks uc
merced
and i told him why son i said why did
you pick it's fine i said you go
wherever you want but i'm curious why
did you pick your mercedes he said well
these are the schools that are
student-centric
in other words they don't focus too much
on research but focus on the students
and success and so i liked all these
three schools i said that but why some
merced they said well the tipping point
was in pacific
uh it says
my brother and you
are alumni
i said yeah that's true
i said and at uc santa barbara my sister
and you are alumni i said yeah so so you
know
i'm going to always be known as you know
the brother the sister or the son of
saying
i want to come and form my own
my my you know create my own
uh route i said well i respect that i
said that's fine
so
the friday
saturday we were supposed to move him in
all right uh and this is a few months
back when the semester was starting we
were supposed to move him in the storm
and everything
and but the friday before one day before
i get a call from the governor's office
and says uh you've been appointed
as a uc regent
so now i'm at uc regent
you know overseeing the 10 uc campuses
uh the national labs lawrence livermore
lab is falls under my purview also so so
so
we go the next day saturday i thought
nothing i said oh thank you very much i
appreciate yes i accept and all that so
the following day i go
and uh with my son and my wife and there
we are moving him in
and as we're moving him in along comes
the chancellor his assistant the the
photographer he's taking pictures with
my son and i cause i'm the new regent
you know and uh
and my son looks up well he looks down
on me because he's taller than me he
looks down at me he says i'm never going
to get rid of you am i
no you're not
so so i'm also on the uc board of
regents
impressive man impressive um well look
we're going on i think over three hours
right now three and a half yeah three
wow
time flies doesn't stop it does indeed
is that that's probably your typical
interview anyway right yeah yeah around
three something between three or four
yeah yeah something like good i'm glad i
had enough material to at least meet the
the norms here you met the minimum
requirements all right
i met the minimum requirement it's just
it's it's a fascinating story and it's
just unbelievable to hear gary you got
any final questions just an incredible
story uh thanks you know thanks for
sharing all the lessons from from your
dad and from your story i mean it's just
incredible man thank you yeah oh the one
thing miss young remember i told you not
to let me forget oh yeah
i was just about to remind you okay
don't worry all right
yes yeah good good i'm glad i'm glad you
reminded me i'm just kidding i forgot
i've dropped the ball
uh
with miss young you know one of the
things is uh
when you go off on the mission uh you
get to invite a hundred
people in the vip section that's about
you know about five six miles from the
launch pad so that's pretty close too
and for a hispanic family it's like okay
which of my cousins aren't coming right
we're so large but but but thank god i
had caucasian crewmates that didn't have
quite a hundred
relatives so i was able to siphon off
wheat
i was able to siphon off a bunch of
tickets and so i had the school district
look up miss young
and miss bail
now i couldn't look up mr sandejas
because he passed away in a car accident
uh but but i
the three most important teachers and
also uh mr rodriguez he also passed away
of cancer so two of two two of them were
gone and um and and so i looked them up
and i had them invited and flown
uh they were sitting next to my parents
both miss bao and miss young were
sitting next to my parents uh witnessing
in
real life there the launch of the space
shuttle and uh and the impact that they
had on me you know i thought that was uh
kind of only right thing to do and try
to get them out there and have that
experience with us
man
outstanding outstanding well um
you know again thank you so much thank
you so much for joining us um thanks for
sharing your story thanks for sharing
your experiences thanks for sharing your
lessons learned
unbelievable lessons learned and and
thanks
for what you've done for mankind to
you know not only in the medical field
and then in the final frontier of space
and then on top of that what you're
continuing to do right now with your
foundations um trying to get out there
and get kids pointed in the right
direction you know we talked about
what happens when kids get pointed in
the wrong direction we know how that
turns out it's horrible and to see
someone like you that we're able to
overcome those boundaries and overcome
the ultimate boundaries and make it to
where you've made it just so much to
learn and i just want to say thanks for
coming on and thanks for sharing we
appreciate it well thank you very much
and i noticed you have a twitter too
right and so i want to invite people to
uh
to to uh
get into my twitter which is astro
underscore jose so if you guys come and
follow me and uh and you're on instagram
as well yeah that instro underscore jose
yeah on twitter at
under astro underscore jose and then
once again the foundation is astrojh.org
yes and then
tierra luna engineering
luna sellers that's where we can find
you we can we can either launch
satellites or we can have a glass of
wine you got us covered and if you drink
enough wine it's probably both
thanks jose appreciate it thank you
jacob it was great being here and uh
thank you for the time and uh and you
were yeah you're very generous with your
time and i'm glad we were able to uh go
over my story and i hope folks enjoy it
and like i said if they want to get some
more buy the book and uh and read it
i think it goes well with a glass of
wine myself
you got us covered thanks jose all right
thank you
and with that
jose hernandez has left the building
man very cool unbelievable story
everything full circle with that guy
everything amazing man just incredible
story uh obviously
he set a high bar on a long journey i
always come out of these things thinking
to myself well
i better raise the game
i better raise the bar i better do a
little bit better
i think that's what we i think is what
we all need to do okay dog
what do you got how can we raise the
game what do we need to do what do you
got for us so we're we're raising the
game on a
strategic level and a tactical level
right at all times strategic level
tactical
getting it right check this out so i'm
gonna start tactical though and that's
jocko fuel for me rtd go and it can
need that hitter
tactical solution right but it doesn't
stop there yeah it it serves the the
greater goal too right the more
strategic goal which is staying on the
path staying healthy not polluting my
body with sugar and freaking chemicals
chemicals preservatives additives right
so we're doing both here with the uh the
jocko fuel or uh jocko go rtd cans
shack getting after dog ready right now
you spent all night thinking of that
didn't you nah bro speak i i just
cracked this go about 20 minutes ago in
it it came to me when we were talking uh
to jose man yeah you know he was always
he was always moving making little
tactical moves that were serving that
greater vision um and even you know even
when it came to when he was talking
about retiring you know that strategic
vision was still you know taking care of
the family he had achieved that that
highest goal and now the the vision was
to take care of his family make sure
they were good to go let's just rock and
roll now it's thinking strategic at all
time and you're right and i sort of
talked about this with that idea of the
of the deviation right and the
acceptance of deviation and how one
minute you're like yeah you know what
it's just one doughnut and you just
start to accept that you start to accept
that you start to accept it don't accept
it
don't accept it you gotta stay on the
freaking path you can't accept these
deviations from the path you gotta get
and if you deviate look if you deviate
get back on it
so that's where we're at
yeah get you know get get something
that's good for you you can drink
something that's literally good for you
you don't have to drink something that's
poison for your body which seems cra it
seems crazy that in this day and age
we have to tell people hey you don't
have to poison yourself but people the
the companies that make this stuff have
figured out oh we can get people
addicted to
sugar we got them addicted to the rush
that they're going to get
and that fake dopamine hit that they're
gonna get and it's all lies and it's
literally bad for you you might as well
just go
and just just hit up the local freaking
drug dealer
and get some of that meth going that's
where you're at that's what you're doing
to your body that's what you're doing in
your mind don't do it
instead get something that's literally
good for you 100 and and i've got i've
got friends who who are addicted
addicted to energy drinks and in thus
addicted to everything that comes along
with that energy drink and it is
it can lead to catastrophic failure
right productive we we don't want to do
that so jack i go rtd we also have joint
warfare uh super krill oil uh
disciplined powder we've also got the
new pre-workout got that in the sniper
flavor great feet and i'll just just
straight just
just drew in the dry what do they call
it
dry scooping dry he's dry scooping that
and now i've seen other people just
drive chasing it with a cell phone
so legit
um
so yeah get get that stuff the joint
warfare the super crew it's that's how
you're gonna had a sealed buddy of mine
call me the other day he goes hey bro i
gotta ask you a question he's my i went
through buzz with this matter of fact
and he he was like uh are you sore every
day or is that what's going on i go hey
man you got the i go you got joining
warfare he goes yeah i go you got super
cool he goes yeah and i go and you're
sore and he goes yeah and i go well quit
complaining yeah
like there's that's as good as you're
going to get like you're saying you're
getting a little older
but you don't want to go off that stuff
got to get that
if if you're still sore bro if that's
that muscle soreness the doms
get on that mulk train get on where are
you at
so we got we got uh by the way speaking
of mulk i just got to mention this yeah
it's
hot
milk season cause it's winter time even
here in california look even here in
california
it gets a little look it's a little cold
a little cooler in the morning time
right so you gotta and this is the key
point
is you gotta warm the milk first don't
put milk in milk and then warm it up
you gotta warm the milk then put the
mold in i'll do an instructional video
as we approach this i've never done hot
milk oh bro whoa it's like hot chocolate
but it's good for you so
yeah stand by for that instructional
video you're good to go
uh yep so get yourself some milk
whatever flavors you want vita vitamin d
three
there you should 100 beyond that for
your life
same thing with cold war oh oh it's it's
winter time there's germs around cool
just crushing with cold water we're
fighting back on this side on the side
all day long uh look you can get this
stuff at vitamin shop you get all of it
at vitamin chop you can get the drinks
at wawa go get a wawa just just clear
the shelves
you can also get it from
jackalfuel.com and if you subscribe to
any of these things which is a good call
on multiple fronts
first of all it's a good call on the
health front because now you don't wake
up
sore and broken because you miss joint
warfare you don't go to bed with a with
a craving in your stomach because you
didn't have any mold left don't let that
happen just subscribe and that's one
front health front other front is
financial front
if you subscribe to something we're
paying the shipping homes we're here for
you get that free freight get that free
freight going on
so there you go
uh another thing that we've got is
well we got origin main origin usa
originusa.com
we're making
stuff
you see my post the other day we're
making stuff we're making jeans we're
making boots we're making geese for that
jiu jitsu
we're making sweatshirts hats well just
what what you need what that's what you
what what you need rash guards what you
need we're making it we got a safety tow
boot now we got work
heavy duty work pants
just what you need and it's all made in
america and it's not just made
this is the thing i'm i'm big on this
right now the made in america thing not
not just made in america but what origin
is doing right now in america bringing
manufacturing back to not just maine now
but north carolina too
where where origin is in north carolina
is 30 minutes from where i grew up
that's huge man to know that
down the road there are kids in my
hometown right now that can go get a job
at origin are you freaking kidding me
i'm fired up now i'm kidding you
not just made in the usa originated
because the material originated in
america the workers originated this is
american made
and it's how we're gonna win the
economic war absolutely so there you go
check it out originusa.com get some
stuff get some stuff oh wait it's
christmas time get some stuff for
christmas
hey what if you could get a gift for
your
friend family member whatever you could
get them a gift and you could give
america
a gift of support
what if you made their future better
because you bought something that was
american-made i'm just saying the
option's there you don't have to buy
something from a communist
you don't have to do that you can you
can you can
but you don't have to jack jack called
me out in austin straight up saw my
jeans wasn't wearing oh it wasn't damn
yeah what he was like he was like hey
you know we got a company that makes
those in america i was like oh it burned
me up right so
i got full benefit from that black
friday deal at origin tell you what
delta 68 is inbound
check all right so there you go
originusa.com go get some uh we also
have our own store jacostore.com
we've got the discipline equals freedom
shirts on there rash guards t-shirts uh
hats beanies uh it is officially a
hoodie season yeah i think we can all
agree when you're going hot monk you're
in a hoodie season 100
hoodie season squat season that's what
we're doing uh we've got hoodies there
we've got women's gear
we've got
warrior kids soap made by aiden out
there getting after it irish oaks farms
jocko soap out here staying clean
we've also got the shirt locker uh my
brother echo charles making who my
brother echo charles the big boy is that
the other guy that's here sometimes
echo charles is making a new shirt every
month and they are certified legit
shirts uh certified legit we were just
at the jocko live saw you know troopers
out there with the warpath shirt on with
the jocko riding the tank i mean just
all of all of these awesome shirts get
on the shirt locker again subscription
situation there so subscribe to this
podcast on itunes google play stitch or
wherever you're listening to um
leave reviews man they are hilarious and
jocko reads them and they're awesome
yeah sometimes sometimes they're just
cool you know good but sometimes they're
funny i haven't done a i haven't done a
review in a while i'm reading one of
those i need to get back on that train
also we have the jocko unraveling that i
do with my friend daryl cooper dc we
have the grounded podcast which we
haven't recorded in a long time is that
thing dead what are we doing you know we
need to get it undead yeah we all are
doing jiu jitsu we talk about i just
need to hit record got a jiu jitsu shirt
yeah
yeah we got two g2 t-shirts on
jacquardstore.com so we'll get back to
that grounded podcast we have the
warrior kid podcast for the warrior kids
out there we also have jocko
underground.com as you know look there's
situations where we
we have been banned in certain scenarios
we don't like that at all i probably got
banned today possibly because i told
people to get off their phones and get
get off fight the algorithm fight the
algorithm how happy do you think that
algorithm controllers are when they hear
that i bet you that thing gets beat down
and freaking alarms going unmonetized
yeah they have like freaking alerts
going off in in brain control mind
control brainwash central they're like
hey we got a rebel here we need to put
down
yeah they're fighting fight against the
algorithm so look we don't know what's
gonna happen
we push against the algorithm hard
enough algorithm's going to push back
they'll push us right off but guess what
we'll be okay we'll be standing by at
jockowunderground.com where we have
we have a little oasis set up
it costs eight dollars and eighteen
cents a month but
if you can't afford it that's okay email
assistance at jockowunderground.com
and and we do a podcast we do a separate
podcast on there kind of like as a thank
you it's a thank you q a answer a bunch
of q a talk about some other subjects
that are tangential to what we talk
about on jocko podcast but most
important it just is a contingency in
case something goes haywire and we have
to abandon the major platforms it's okay
we'll be in jockowunderground.com you
can also find us on youtube um jocko
podcast youtube channel subscribe there
got some uh great videos up of the
podcast where you can see what jocko and
echo
so look when echo
can you explain that
when i talk about being the aed
and kind of coming through at the
critical moments and and see what echo's
doing the good tactical move he's made
it seem like that's funny ha ha he was
like he went with that to make it seem
like yeah jackal is just kidding because
he doesn't want he doesn't want to say
the truth
which is as you know at the critical
junctures at the critical junctures
there's usually a little bit of like you
know that that little connective tissue
right hey look echo brings he brings the
major bulk of the of the muscle mass to
the scenario but that achilles tendon
you got it i've got to get rid of it so
the assistant director myself let's face
it sometimes i got to come in with a big
win
i'm you've seen it i've i've seen it but
i will also say i will also say that
echo charles is open-minded in these
scenarios he's straight up luckily he's
humble enough
and he knows he doesn't push back when
that when the when when
when the assistant director comes in and
makes a suggestion echo charles is
humble enough to say
yeah jacob's right again
open-minded open-minded for sure
but we so we're we've got those videos
up on our youtube channel origen also
has an amazing uh youtube channel where
they show you what it's like to bring
manufacturing back to america uh check
them out on youtube as well we've also
got psychological warfare
which is an album with tracks of jocko
helping you out of moments of weakness
um highly recommended there that's the
fundamentals you want to get reps in on
the fundamentals go hit psychological
warfare i owe another one of those
albums by the way i know
totally yeah all right i gotta
prioritize and execute that uh if you
want something cool to hang on your wall
don't worry dakota meyer's got you
covered cool stuff to hang on your wall
which is all you need to say
comes from dakota meyer and it's cool
stuff to hang on your wire wall check
out flipsidecanvas.com
order something for yourself made in
america by the way also
got some books
final spin
to get
i i can't say too much about it
but let's let's face it if you haven't
read final spin you want to you probably
need to
go get that go get that there you go
there's your advice leadership strategy
and tactics field manual the code the
evaluation the protocols discipline
equals freedom field manual
weigh the warrior kid one two three and
four that's what i'm trying to do
kids are out there they need those books
they need to be on the path they need to
get steered straight unlike carlos and
alberto and sergio that you heard about
on this podcast today
get the kids on the path weigh the
warrior kid one two three four there's
christmas
there's a life-changing christmas is
that a bold statement
no it's not actually life-changing
christmas get way of the warrior kid one
two three and four for all the kids that
you know make an investment every kid
that you know get them all four of those
books
change their life get them on the path
if you got little kids get them miking
the dragons best little kids books ever
extreme ownership
dichotomy of leadership
that i wrote with my brother leif babin
don't forget about about face
by colonel david hackworth i wrote the
forward on the new edition we have a
leadership consultancy
it's called echelon front we solve
problems through leadership no matter
what's going on leadership is the
solution leadership is the solution go
to echelonfront.com for details there
you can also come to one of our live
events
we have the muster we have field
training exercises we have ef
battlefield we have the next muster is
in dallas texas march 24th and 25th if
you want to come and get some of that
we also have an online training program
called extreme ownership academy
leadership is not something you just
learn and you're good it's not like that
it's something that you have to train in
constantly it's something that you have
to work on constantly it's something
that you improve on all the time
it's a perishable skill by the way
so that's why we created
the extreme ownership academy go to
extremeownership.com
i'm on there three times a week two
times a week four times a week answering
questions you want to talk to me if
you're like oh i'd really like to meet
y'all just go on there that's that's the
other thing about this leadership skill
is that it helps to have a guiding you
know a guiding hand a mentor you know
somebody who knows what they're talking
about helping you along the path you
guys do that three times a week uh you
and leif you know on a
live event uh you know jp dave are the
echelon front instructors guiding you
through this stuff i mean
it's a no-brainer yep that's it go to
extremeownership.com come and hang out
come and learn
and if you want to help service members
active and retired you want to help
their families
gold star families check out mark lee's
mom mama lee she's got a charity
organization doing all kinds of awesome
stuff for veterans
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to america's
mightywarriors.org
and if you want
well
if you want more of my um what is it
marathon mumbling
which is what i seem to do
if you want
more of carrie's
inquisitive inquiries well then you can
go on the interwebs
on twitter on instagram and on facebook
carries at carrie underscore helton i'm
at jocko willink and also
don't forget that
astro underscore
jose is where you can reach
jose hernandez and also he has the
reaching for the stars foundation
astrojh.org
so you can check that out as well and
then as you heard him say he's got tira
luna
and tierra luna sellers
tiaralunasellers.com tierra luna
engineering was an engineering
engineering of tierluna engineering.com
if you want to get some help getting
into space or you want to drink some
wine
jose's got you covered which is awesome
and for all those men and women out
there
right now in the army navy air force
marines
thank you for keeping us safe here on
earth
and also thanks to our police law
enforcement firefighters paramedics emts
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol secret service and all first
responders
thanks for keeping us safe
here at home
and to everyone else out there
remember
remember jose hernandez his family give
us an incredible example
of what hard work and persistence
12 years of persistence by the way
persistence can do for us and he gave us
a simple plan to follow
identify your goal identify where you
are in relation to that goal map out a
way to get there
educate yourself thoroughly around that
goal
put in the work
people don't want to hear about that
step put in the work working at a
cannery
from ten o'clock at night till six
o'clock in the morning then going to
class at nine in the morning
getting two and a half hours of sleep
when you get to home from school going
back to the cannery that's putting in
work
that's putting in work
and finally never give up
persistence
persistence persistence persistence
persistence 12 rejection letters i guess
it was 11 rejection letters got it on
the 12th 11 rejection letters 11 years
of rejection
and what am i doing what can i do how
can i get better where can i improve
and on top of all that listen
it's the journey it's the process it's
the track it's the voyage that are the
most important part and if
if you go on that path even if you don't
make it to the end of the path if you go
on that path look at how much further
you are along in life look about how
much better you have improved as a human
being so relish the struggle and even
relish when you come up short which you
will that's part of it
keep reaching
keep scratching
and no matter what keep getting after it
and until next time this is carrie and
jocko
out